Guten Morgen Linus.
284 Sendung jetzt ich finde wir könnten langsam mal viral gehen.
Dann müssen wir ein Lynchmob Anfällen am besten auf WhatsApp.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 284 vom 28 Januar 2018 und ich weiß nicht also.
Mit der Reichweite ob du das jetzt richtig Methoden vorschlägst gerade.
Ich beobachte nur und lerne.
Von wem denn.
Von CT scan viral geht wir müssen auf jeden Fall mehr Fake News machen und nahrhaft.
Das ist beides nicht unbedingt unsere Stärken.
Nee das stimmt.
Wobei ich es ja letzte Woche schon versucht habe mit Fake News.
Ich habe Korrekturen bekommen und zwar wichtige und richtige.
Denn ich habe Gäste letzte Woche über Hawaii pinpoint im Prinzip direkt zwei Sachen nachvollziehbar und eindrücklich hätte ich auch beim sagen merken müssen falsch erzählt
die ich in den Kommentaren mehrfach korrigiert bekommen habe dafür herzlichen Dank
bin ganz froh dass das in solchen Fällen dann doch sehr gut funktioniert.
Ja die Leute hören einen wirklich zu.
Ja die können wirklich zu das war eine Übung zur Prüfung eurer Medienkompetenz nein das war einfach nur Schluss den ich geredet habe erstens,
habe ich gesagt bei heberden point würden keine E-Mails gespeichert werden das ist nicht richtig und das hätte ich auch.
Also ich weiß nicht genau was ich kann ich weiß warum ich sag gleich wie ich dazu gekommen bin das zu sagen aber genau also es werden Emails gespeichert die speichern die.
Betroffenen E-Mail-Adressen und in welchem
leg diese E-Mail-Adressen betroffen sind um Ihnen diese Auskunft geben zu können das muss natürlich auch so sein denn sonst wird ja dieses Feature mit der Domain notification nicht funktionieren wenn ihr also im Besitz einer
ganzen Domain seit was weiß ich Linus Bindestrich neumann.de oder Logbuch Bindestrich Netzpolitik de.
Dann könnt ihr dort auch Nachweise dass euch die gesamte Domain gehört dann bekommt ihr auch über alle E-Mail Adressen dieser Domain eine Notification und das würde ja nicht gehen
wenn die nicht die E-Mail-Adressen im Plaintext dort gespeichert hat.
Aber sonst wäre ja nur ein Hash und man könnte nur vergleichen ob diese eine ist die man gerade.
Richtig und das habe ich da falsch dargestellt II was ich falsch erklärt habe war die.
Pound passwords Epi von.
MHW bin Pound wo man also ein für eingegebenes Passwort prüfen kann.
Ob es in dieser Datenbank ist und da habe ich das Speicherkonzept verwechselt,
dem von Lars Pass welches ein Passwort Manager in der Cloud ist in den ich mich kurz vor der Sendung eingelesen hatte und da habe ich dann einfach die beiden.
Der Speicherkonzepte vollständig durcheinander gebracht also wie funktioniert die Point Passwort Sepia ihr errechnet Lokal,
die Prüfsumme von eurem Passwort das heißt für den Zeitpunkt hat das Passwort eure,
euren Rechner noch nicht verlassen und die Prüfsumme dir da errechnet ist eine SHA1 Prüfsumme die hat insgesamt 160.
Bitte also irgendwie,
ein möglichkeitenraum mit sowas wie 48 Nullen oder sowas relativ große Möglichkeiten wie viele es da gibt und ihr schickt dann von dieser Prüfsumme nur,
die ersten 5 Zeichen in der hexadezimal Repräsentation,
nur die ersten 5 Zeichen von insgesamt müssten das dann 40 Zeichen sein.
Die ihr dann dorthin schickt also die ersten 5 Zeichen von einem sehr viel länger von einer sehr viel längeren Prüfsumme schickt ihr dorthin und dann bekommt ihr von der von der App hier zurück,
alle dort vertretenen Prüfsummen die mit diesen fünf Zeichen beginnen.
Und zu den jeweiligen Prüfsummen wie oft sie da drin waren und das ist sehr elegant weil das auf eine Weise,
Doppel blind ist ihr verratet nur die ersten 5 Zeichen eurer sehr viel längeren Brühe.
Und die Antwort die ihr bekommt sind alle vertreten impressum die mit diesen fünf Zeichen beginnen,
ob das aber überhaupt eure Prüfsumme ist das prüft ihr wiederum Lokal.
Und wenn man sich anschaut wie viele Zeichen halt noch übrig sind in der Prüfsumme die ihr habt ist es also sehr gut möglich dass sie eine vollständig andere habt die nicht in dieser Liste vertreten ist.
Und dann könnt ihr aber diese Entscheidung trefft ihr Lokal das heißt,
wenn ihr mit dieser App hier redet weiß die LP 1 nicht die vollständige Prüfsumme eures Passwortes und ihr wiederum,
kriegt kriegt eine Auswahl an Antworten und die Epi weiß noch nicht einmal ob ihr am Ende ein unsicheres Passwort habt oder nicht also es ist tatsächlich dort für blind und das ist auf diese Weise sehr elegant gelöst dann.
Also so so kann man das machen ja fünf Zeichen einer 160 Bit SHA1 Prüfsumme kann man schon mal verraten,
war ja noch genug Entropie übrig ist am Ende der Prüfsumme und so kann man.
So kann man arbeiten sag mir aber natürlich uns längere Zeitdauer unterhalten dass man trotzdem Leute nicht animieren möchte einfach.
Ihre Passwörter in Weboberflächen einzugeben und da haben wir dann auch in den Kommentaren ein einfaches perl script
die Kommunikation mit dieser LPE durchführt wo ihr also quasi genau
prüfen könnt aha hier wird diese SHA1 Prüfsumme errechnet hier werden die ersten 5 Zeichen genommen die werden dorthin geschickt was ich zurückbekomme die dieser dieses Array diese Sammlung an password Hash ist die werden,
wieder Gerät wieder geprüft mit meinem eigenen.
Und dann kann man so in der Form tatsächlich damit arbeiten wie das immer so ist mit mit Code den jemand anders geschrieben hat und empfohlen hat.
Sollte man trotzdem verstehen bevor man ihn tatsächlich ausführt also wenn er das nicht versteht dann lass da lasst euch von jemandem helfen der versteht.
Und dann könnt ihr die Spawn password API verwenden.
Bitte eine sehr elegante Methode alles geheim zu halten nur zum Verständnis also hier wenn nicht die ersten 5 Zeichen des Passworts gesendet sondern bezieht sich immer alles nur auf diese Hashes und bleibt von daher die ganze Zeit in der Wolke und unklar.
Genau also aus den Aussehen Hashes.
Kommt man nicht zurück auf das Passwort und erst recht nicht aus den ersten 5 Zeichen des Herrschers insofern so so ist das schön so gehört sich das und wenn diese Kommunikation sichergestellt ist dann kann man es besser,
wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Sorry dass ich das falsch erklärt habe wie gesagt ich habe mich vorher mit Lars Pass auseinandergesetzt und bin da einfach vollständig in diesen beiden Erklärungen vermischt und hin und her gesurft und habe da Äpfel mit Birnen verwechselt.
Und dann gibt's noch einen wichtigen dritten Hinweis das auch wirklich nur über mich.
Was hast du eigentlich gegen Dichter und Denker.
Was habe ich gegen Enzensberger nichts habe ich gegen erstens Berger.
Ich weiß noch genau wie ich in dieser Sendung sagt und ich wollte sagt wie hieß noch mal dieser bekloppte der früher bei der Vater geschrieben hat und dann zur Verschwörungstheoretiker beim Kopp Verlag wurde und was für ein Ziel war
Voßkuhle und dann dachte ich sofort coole kann es nicht sein dass sich der Vorsitzende Verfassungsgericht.
Das ist irgend so ein komischer Name und dann der richtige komischer Name wäre gewesen Ulfkotte,
also Voßkuhle Ulfkotte wenn ich dich kennt ihr seid auf Ulfkotte wichtig gekommen ist ich habe ich Enzensberger gesagt weil ich alles 3 komische deutsche Namen finde,
also der Verschwörungstheoretiker ist Ulfkotte und der ist dann alles aber inzwischen schon Tod den hat es relativ früh erwischt.
Und im Entenberg erlebt glaube ich noch Voßkuhle auch beide bleiben uns bitte erhalten und beide schreiben bisher nicht beim Kopf Alltag und ich hoffe dass es dabei bleibt,
sorry dass ich da durcheinander gekommen.
Du hast wahrscheinlich die ersten 5 Zeichen des Namens irgendwie in dein Heft reingetan.
Ich habe nur die ersten 5 Zeichen gehasht und dann bin ich hier ein bisschen durcheinander gekommen.
Das kann schon mal passiern ne.
Sorry ansonsten bleibt das Thema Passwort-Safe ein.
Ein spannendes Thema in den Kommentaren und E-Mails sie so bekomme,
ich glaube es war sogar schon in der vorletzten Sendung gestern relativ viel drüber gesprochen wurde ja das.
Also was ist die Rolle von OpenSource und sicher ja also das quasi gesagt wurde da XY ist nicht sicher weil nicht OpenSource,
oder XY ist sicher weil OpenSource und ich bestelle regelmäßig fest dass.
Hier teilweise viel Schlüsse gezogen werden deswegen würde ich das gerne mal kurz aussprechen das Thema eine Software kann natürlich sicher sein.
Unabhängig davon ob sie OpenSource ist oder nicht das ist zunächst einmal,
ja ein ganz anderes Feature ja also dann ganz eine ganz eigene ein ganz anderer Bereich Software kann eine
hat die Software eine hohe Qualität oder nicht ist erstmal unabhängig davon
ob sie OpenSource ist oder nicht ja es gibt Open-Source-Software in schlechter Qualität und es gibt closed source software in schlechter Qualität das ist zunächst einmal unabhängig Kernfrage bei dieser Open-Source Geschichte ist.
Das Vertrauen ja und wie wir alle wissen vertrauen ist gut aber Kontrolle ist besser und wenn man richtig paranoid werden möchte wir wollen ja gar nicht vertrauen müssen sondern wir wollen,
sicher sein das ist ja das eigentliche Thema hier.
Und da kommt natürlich die Überlegung zum Tragen mit der Open-Source-Software bei Open-Source-Software kann eine Kontrolle erfolgen.
Bei Closed Source Software in der Regel nicht ich komme gleich noch mal.
So einfach ja.
Ich komme gleich noch mal kurz den Einschränkungen,
so deswegen heißt es wenn es wirklich um hoch Sicherheitsanwendungen geht dann ist natürlich die Open-Source-Software deshalb zu bevorzugen weil man sie kontrollieren,
kann aber diese Kontrolle muss natürlich auch jemanden machen,
somit wenn das nicht passiert dann ist OpenSource am Ende und da sich als Gesichtspunkten genauso,
kritisch oder unkritisch zu betrachten wie closed source also opens den Sicherheitsgewinn oder den Vertrauens und den Kontroll Gewinn bei Open-Source-Software haben wir nur wenn auch jemand,
diese Kontrolle durchführt und es wird sehr häufig der Fehlschluss gemacht dass etwas nur weil es Open Source ist.
Sicher sein das ist ein Fake.
Ja das haben wir auch vor allem gesehen insbesondere hatten das ja ja auch glaube ich mehrfach schon drin
Open SSL die library die viele Software benutzt hat um diese SSL-Verschlüsselung zu machen da sind dann halt irgendwann mal so ganz haarsträubende Fehler gefunden die da halt auch schon seit Jahren fast einem Jahrzehnt
drin rum lagen und
obwohl es halt so dieses Prinzip von wem war das noch mal von Eric Raymond der hat ja mal diesen the cathedral and the bazaar in diesem epischen Text zu Open Source Entwicklung gesagt so gif,
enough eyeballs all bugs are shellona sind noch Leute hin gucken dann sind halt irgendwie alle Ligen alle Fehler irgendwie offen zutage
ja nur dann brauchst halt auch diese eyeballs bzw müssen halt auch hin gucken und das
dieses Verständnis für Security auch etwas ist wahrscheinlich erst den letzten Jahren so richtig gereift ist und bei Leuten sind Selbstverständlichkeit erzeugt dass man darauf zu achten hat zeigt sich eben das eben infeel Open Source,
Tanz haarsträubende Bugs noch rum lagen und die sich einfach so keiner gekümmert.
Genau und der da kann man natürlich jetzt mal draufschauen warum ist das so ja ich habe da mit einem guten Freund von mir auch regelmäßig Gespräche drüber der.
In der Körne und Linux Entwicklung und so weiter tätig ist und sagt weißt du wir schreiben
irgendwie tausende Zeilen zehntausende Zahlen open source code
der irgendwie in aller Welt verwendet wird ne und bauen hier an der großen Dinos Geschichte und alle alle paar Monate oder Jahre
kommt irgendsoein Security researcher vorbei findet irgend einen klitzekleinen Fehler und trommelt sich auf die Brust und sagt hier wie cool ich bin ich habe ein Fehler gefunden und ihr seid alle doof
ja so ein bisschen Lust die Perspektive der,
der kreativen soll ich mal der der schaffenden auf dieses Phänomen und das ist natürlich auch ein,
also auch eine eine Perspektive die man die natürlich da gegeben sein muss ja weshalb ich grundsätzlich ja immer dafür plädiere.
Es ist wichtig diese Kontrollarbeit und diese qualitätssicherungs Arbeit auch
zu ermutigen denn der Unterschied ist dieser Sicherheitsforscher der NADA vorbeikommen und sich irgendwie auf die Brust klopft weil er weil er ein Fehler gefunden hat der macht das in der Regel in seiner Freizeit oder unbezahlt ja vielleicht gibt's mal ein Bug Bounty oder so,
aber in Wirklichkeit wäre es sehr sehr viel schöner wenn wir vielmehr auch diese Qualitätssicherung and.
Mit Anreizen Versehen würden was übrigens etwas ist was wir rccc die ganze Zeit,
fordern ja ist so eigentlich jedesmal wenn wir zu allgemeineren Fragen der IT Sicherheit gefragt werden sagen wir
bitte bitte bitte erhöht doch die staatliche Förderung von
Qualitätssicherung in der Open-Source-Software mit anderen Worten Bug Bounties wo also der eine unabhängige Stelle sagt,
finde eine Schwachstelle in diesem Open Source Code trage dazu bei dass sie verschwindet.
Und du erhältst als Kompensation für deine Mühen folgendes Kopfgeld was wir auf die Schwachstelle aufge
Sepp Abend und da gibt's ja auch schon von Julia Reda da massiv angestrengt diese ich glaube 1000000 Euro die die
die die Europäische Union da ausgelobt hat für verschiedene Schwachstellen so etwas muss es sehr viel mehr geben.
Denn da komme ich jetzt zu einer etwas unpopulären Sicht für die Open-Source Fanatiker.
Denke immer noch dass eine der besten Methoden die Sicherheit einer Software oder eines Systems
zu beurteilen ist zu schauen was die Schwarzmarkt Preise für eine Schwachstelle darin sind denn je höher die oder
oder die weißmark Preise wenn es bug-bounty es gibt aber in der Regel werden die fetten Preise auf dem Schwarzmarkt bezahlt denn je mehr da die.
Kriminellen und nicht vertrauenswürdigen Instanzen dieser Welt bereit sind zu zahlen,
für eine Schwachstelle desto eher brauchen Sie die im Zweifelsfall und desto sicherer kann ich mich mit dieser Software
also die Schwarzmarkt Preise oder die bug-bounty Preise für Schwachstellen sich anzuschauen ist ein relativ guter Indikator für,
die Softwarequalität.
Ja oder für die Sicherheit einer Software natürlich kann es auch da mal zu hohe Preise geben oder zu niedrige Preise aber als Indikator ist das erstmal in relativ guter.
Guter Blick darauf zu sehen ne wie sieht denn der Markt für Angreifer aus ja,
ist das irgendwie für wenige 10000 € dann Exploit zu haben oder sind wir da im 100000 € Bereich ja und das wiederum zeigt eben.
Die mag Mechanismen dahinter dann auch auf ärgerlicherweise werden die besten Preise immer von denen moralisch wenig gefestigten Instanzen gezahlt.
Im Zweifelsfall am Ende ein Kriminelle und Geheimdienste verkaufen und.
Dem sollten wir vor allem deshalb auch entgegentreten mit mutigen Bug Bounties um eben die gute faire.
Dem gemein die gute faire und gemeinwohlorientierte Sicherheitsforschung entsprechend zu incentivieren und dafür zu sorgen dass jemand der eben gut genug ist irgendwo Schwachstellen zu finden das,
dann,
und nicht sagt ach weißt du was ich kann mir eine Haus kaufen wenn ich diese Schwachstelle hier an jenes komisches unter komisches Unternehmen verkaufe welches mir was weiß ich.
250000 € für diese Schwachstelle bezahlt und ich habe keine weiteren Fragen die gestellt werden müssen.
Und mit diesem diesem Schwarzmarkt müssen wir dann leider konkurrieren und es ist notwendig dass wir da als Gesellschaft ernstzunehmende Angebote schaffen sonst passieren uns immer wieder solche Scherze,
wie du es gerade schon angesprochen hast wie wir es mit Open SSL gesehen haben der heartbleed bug ne oder wie letzte Woche wunderschön passiert mit sevenzip.
Sevenzip eine recht beliebte Kompressions Software die Leute immer benutzen weil sie weil sie sagt ja wir wir verschlüsseln die Dateien mit AES.
Da hat sich jetzt hier offen Sicherheitsforscher namens Michael Stanek gesagt,
ach ja okay wenn ich das verwenden soll naja ist ja auch im voraus dann schaue ich mal kurz rein und findet sofort halt irgendwie eklatante Schwächen in der AES Implementierung wo sie nämlich dann den initialisierungsvektor für die Verschlüsselung
mit mit Arbeit machen also quasi letztendlich.
Dal einfach die Verschlüsselung so schwach initialisieren dass es mit geringen Aufwand möglich sein sollte alle,
so auf diese Weise verschlüsselten Dateien zu knacken und diese
Form der Verschlüsselung auf IV alle schwören die sich seit Jahren empfiehlt weil alles an hier das ist alles und hier das ist OpenSource hat halten nie jemand die Kontrolle gemacht und da haben wir natürlich dann ein Ungleichgewicht von.
Von Vertrauen und da denke ich müssen wir,
politisch gegensteuern da muss relativ dir Geld darein dass wir sagen ok diese Open-Source-Software die
die pflegen wir dass es ohnehin ein Problem die Open-Source-Software ist in der Regel underhanded wenn wir jetzt nicht irgendwie vom Linux-Kernel reden ne.
Das heißt ich hier wollen wir Qualitätssicherung hier wollen wir
vor allem qualitativ hochwertige Programmierer haben und dann müssen wir gemäß dieser dieser Forderungen public money public code noch sehr sehr viel besser werden nicht nur in Deutschland sondern auch.
Ja das von dir erwähnte Projekt was Julia Reda und noch ein weiterer Parlaments Kollege ist nämlich jetzt gerade nicht erinnere angeregt haben heißt hossa
EU free and open source software auditing Community und das läuft doch immer noch hat eine zweite Auflage bekommen.
Projekte wie KeePass und Apache sind da halt angefordert worden um ebensolche Audits dann durchzuführen.
Ich glaube sevenzip war da auch irgendwie im Bug Bounty program oder sowas ich weiß nicht genau wie das weitergeht aber so oder so guter erster wichtiger Schritt aber wie sie sagte Frank kürzlich.
Im Prinzip könnten wir so die die wichtige Software zu einem Bruchteil des Preises eines Jäger 90 oder einer,
eines durchschnittlichen Auftrages an McKinsey der deutschen Bundeswehr in Deutschland entscheidende Fortschritte machen ja.
Dann kam noch kurz dieser eine Frage ja wie sieht das denn aus wenn man so eine wenn man so Passwort Ableitungen hat ja also irgendwie Domainname,
+ Master Passwort gehasht und das ist dann wiederum das Passwort mit dem man sich einloggt na ja hat das gleiche Problem.
Es gibt ein Masterpasswort und wenn das einmal betroffen wurde.
Dann wird man alles andere werdet ihr alle Passwörter ändern müssen und genau davor soll euch ja,
Passwort safe schützen die andere Frage die dann noch kam ist ja was ist aber wenn meine wenn mein Rechner Trojan isiert wird dann liegt ja mit dem Passwort safe alles auf dem Rechner und mit einem Keylogger Krieg
der Angreifer oder die Angreiferin dann auch noch mein Passwort dazu ist zu sagen Trojaner also Schadsoftware auf eurem Rechner.
Immer das Game Over unabhängig davon ob wir jetzt ein Passwort safe verwendet oder nicht wenn eure Maschinen einmal mit shards of er infiziert sind und die Schatz Software ist darauf.
Auslegt eure Passwörter zu klauen er hat Dir ohnehin verloren.
Ja und zwar unabhängig davon ob ihr ein Passwort safe benutzt oder nicht.
Wenn ihr ein Passwort safe benutzt dann wird eben das Passwort zu dem Passwort safe geklaut und alle Passwörter die da drin gespeichert sind wenn ihr keinen benutzt habt ihr die ganze Zeit eure Passwörter ein dann werden die eben geklaut insofern.
Für den Fall dass euer Rechner Trojan isiert wird habt ihr mit einem Passwort safe also eine minimal größere Angriffs Oberfläche aber,
was die Passwort ist ja eigentlich verhindern sind
zu einfach und so kurze Passwörter Wiederverwendung von Passwörtern und sie verhindern größere Probleme wenn ihr mal ein Passwort ändern ist oder eben das Passwort für ein Passwort safe
Ändern wolltest es einfacher die jeweiligen Passwörter zu wechseln.
Insofern Passwort-Safe verringern die Angriffs Oberfläche.
In den Bereichen die im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlicher sind also eure Passwörter werden im Zweifelsfall
er gefunden weil einer der Service ist die er verwendet,
nicht ordentlich auf sie aufgepasst hat eure Passwörter werden eher gefunden weil ihr sie mehrfach verwendet wir eure Passwörter werden eher gefunden weil sie zu einfach und zu kurz sind.
Alf,
dass eure Maschine Trojan isiert wird das ist einfach nur meine Mengen Betrachtung wie werden Passwörter gestohlen das heißt nicht dass das Risiko Szenario per Trojaner werden eure Passwörter gestohlen vor euch nicht auch in Frage kommt.
Aber wenn man einfach nur anschaut wie wird der größere Teil der Passwörter gestohlen dann ist es eben nicht mit Schadsoftware.
Und vor diesem Hintergrund ja ihr habt eine etwas größere Angriffs Oberfläche bei Chartsoftware Infektion Schatz auf der Infektion sind aber nicht euer größtes Risiko,
rein zahlenmäßig betrachtet insofern.
Trotzdem würde ich hier zu einem Passwort safe raten natürlich.
Sind aber die gängigen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen gegen die Infektion von Schadsoftware genauso wichtig dazu gehört
ordentlichen Adblocker zu verwenden ordentlichen Tracker Blocker alles alles raus was man nicht unbedingt braucht was nicht zum Inhalt der Seite gehört.
Alle Software auf dem aktuellen Stand halten
nicht allen scheiß anklicken nicht ein scheiß runterladen nicht ein scheiß installieren also insgesamt einfach Systeme auf dem aktuellen Stand halten und sich und für Fischadler für Infektionen eben auch eine möglichst geringe.
Angriffs Oberfläche be.
Selbst aber auch den Vorteil dass sie einen Halt auf solche liegst auch hinweisen können falls sie sehen halt a-ok du hast hier ein Passwort da und da bei der und der Plattform da gab es jetzt gerade ein liegt ganz unabhängig davon ob wir,
dein Login davon betroffen war oder nicht einfach mal ändern kann ich Schaden wovon.
Valerie bilety ilert es echt schöne also wenn man sich da mal so durch arbeitet und dann ebenso durch ein paar tausend Passwörter geht die man über die Jahre so angehäuft hat und das Ding eine Satire dieses Passwort ist übrigens relativ einfach dieses Passwort hier.
Ist in der Hawaii pinpoint Datenbank und so weiter da kann man richtig schön kann man so richtig schön mein Tag sortieren und dann kann man eben,
auch besser schlafen achso dann war natürlich noch der. Na ja was ist denn wenn ich dieses wenn ich dieses diesen Passwort-Safe synke Jan also über irgend Cloud Angebot ich meine den kannst du.
Was was ich bei Apple in der iCloud legen den Katze in deine nextcloud legen den kannst du über BitTorrent Sync Sünden was auch immer der Sync Mechanismus deiner Wahl ist.
Sofern die Verschlüsselung ordentlich gebaut wurde sollte das im Prinzip egal sein Ja und denn ein Angreifer bräuchte immer noch Zugang.
Zudem Sünching Service den ihr Bett jeder benutzt den wird im Zweifelsfall einfach kriegen.
Deswegen genau ist der Safe ja verschlüsselt dass er dann noch das Passwort dafür braucht das wird im Zweifelsfall nicht so einfach bekommen aber ihr merkt.
Es gibt eben und das ist sich regelmäßig wenn ich irgendwie Vorträge über das Thema halte es gibt nicht das ist.
Hundertprozentig sicher und das nicht es gibt einfach nur eine Überlegung was sind die.
Dominanten Bedrohungsszenarien was sehen wir wie Angriffe funktionieren und was sind gegen diese mehrheitlich
stattfinden Angriffe sinnvolle Verteidigungs Methoden für jede Verteidigungs Methode gibt es auch wieder neues Angriffsszenario und Seis am Ende einfach nur dass ihr nach dem Passwort gefragt werdet ja also ihr werdet keine,
hundertprozentige Sicherheit erlangen das heißt aber nicht dass sie nicht eine bessere Sicherheit erlangen sollt.
Jetzt bist du absolut 100% Medien kompatibel weil du den tollen Satz gesagt hast 100 hundertprozentige Sicherheit wird es nicht geben.
Ja das nervt tschuldigung das ist der der Satz der wird tausendfach zitiert und der wird jedesmal in den falschen Kontext gesetzt weil was die Leute daraus daraus regelmäßig schließen
ist so eine Unsicherheit Nihilismus ist keine Sicherheit geben also lassen also versuchen wir es gar nicht erst das ist falsch,
es gibt einfach ein ganz klares ganz klein. Von das ist das anderes Szenario für das bin ich verwundbar oder nicht und die gear weniger verwundbar ich dafür bin desto sicherer bin ich es heißt nicht dass ich sich her bin.
Und das ist irgendwie der Unterschied ihr könnt euch eben überlegen ob ihr in eurer was weiß ich
euch bevorstehenden Zeit 60 Jahre mit der Informationstechnologie bis ihr euch endlich zur Ruhe setzen können mit den ganzen Scheiß nichts mehr zu tun habt.
Ob ihr in der Zeit bei jeder bei jeder einfachsten Angriff Kampagne sofort mit dabei sein wollt als Opfer oder ob ihr sagt ok bei mir soll es halt ein bisschen besser sein als Bonobo 23.42.
Und entsprechend möchte ich ein bisschen besser dastehen.
Ich bitte dich das war damals ein Qualität Passwort.
Ja also heute noch.
Wo man da überall mit rein kommt ne wenige Passwörter.
Sehr universell einsetzbar.
Universal Passwort.
Ja also das ist echt cool universaler Sport ist sehr gut.
Der ist meine universalpasswort da gibt's ja auch ne also.
Cyberpunk cypherpunks.
Genau das wollte ich auch gerade erwähnen falls ihr irgendwann mal in einem Hotspot steht der euch nicht reinlassen will und wo irgendwelche wo eine Registrierung erforderlich ist probiert es erstmal mit Cyberpunk cypherpunks also mit PH
und das könnte gut sein dass ich das immer noch ausreichend rumgesprochen hat beeilen dass man genau
damit sich registriert um es anderen Leuten sozusagen leicht.
Also es ist immer gut einen Notfall Generalschlüssel dabei.
Frau Dietrich.
Der Daten Dietrich.
Okay.
Dann gucken wir doch mal auf wie die Leute so gut in das funktioniert hat.
Hat sehr gut funktioniert denn wie ich ja schon den letzten Sendung angekündigt habe ich habe ja echt gerade laufen mit den Ankündigungen ich höre jetzt langsam auf Ding an zu können weil die Ankündigung war einfach der letzten Sendung schon gesagt,
nach Kollektion 1.com Kollektion 2 bis 5.
Sie sind auch gekommen bzw Vanja ist schon da sind nur jetzt auch in die Öffentlichkeit in der Öffentlichkeit diskutiert.
Die sind entsprechend größer.
Und dieses Mal war das Hasso-Plattner-Institut schneller als Treuhand der übrigens immer noch mit O,
und y&t geschrieben wird und nicht eure Passwort Treuhand ist
die eurer Passwort Treuhand ist nämlich das Hasso-Plattner-Institut in Potsdam das ebenfalls einen Service anbietet um Adressen zu checken der
identity Leak Checker kurz TLC und der hat jetzt.
Dieses Mal die Kollektion zwei bis fünf auch schneller drin gehabt als ever been point wir reden von.
Milliarden verschiedene Email-Adressen 750 Millionen waren vorher nicht im.
ILC identity Leak Checker und man kann dort eine E-Mail-Adresse,
eingeben und die haben das so gelöst man gib deine E-Mail-Adresse ein und dann schicken die an die E-Mail-Adresse das Ergebnis was ganz nett ist weil,
sage mal ist man kann natürlich heilbar bin Pound.
Auch benutzen gegen Leute ja also wenn man jetzt z.b. sieht aha mich interessiert da mein.
Meine Zielpersonen dann gebe ich das mal gebe ich mal deine E-Mail-Adresse ein bei herber bin Pound und dann steht diese E-Mail-Adresse ist in folgenden liegt vorhanden.
Dann weiß ich schon mal nach welchen liegst ich suchen muss wenn ich die nicht eh schon gesammelt habe er also.
Ich denke das ist nur ein ganz schwacher Abstrich in der B-Note aber es ist trotzdem sehr viel schöner das so zu machen
wie das HPI dass man einfach dann per E-Mail informiert im Zweifelsfall kommt ihr an diese geliebten Passwort Dateien ohnehin dran
oder kommt ein Angreifer da dran insofern ist das jetzt nicht,
Mission Skritt ich diese Informationen öffentlich auch anzugeben aber schöner ist es auf jeden Fall so wie das HPE das hier gemacht hat ich habe beim HP ihr aber nicht
eine Domain Suche gefunden was das für mich dann leider größtenteils unbrauchbar macht.
Bitte deine E-Mail-Adresse nicht alle auswendig.
Nee die kenne ich nicht alle auswendig die müsst ihr aus dem Passwort safe exportieren.
Könnte ich auch mal machen aber dann werde ich bin ich der doofen mit mit mit Copy und pace und so.
Das mal ausprobiert mal gucken was die Antwort.
Also eine Domain de Domain Suche wer schon ist schon ewig her was man haben.
So, endlich mal ich hoffe dieses Thema jetzt endlich hinter uns gelassen zu haben aber ich muss aufhören ich freue mich tatsächlich das hat,
glaube ich jetzt meinen nachhaltig gewirkt also was ich so oft fütter lese anzieht was ich an
E-Mails bekommen was ich einen Kommentar in der zu der Sendung sehe haben sich wirklich eine größere Menge Leute jetzt dazu entschieden
Mall in ihren Passwörtern aufzuräumen und da ein zeitgemäßes Konzept an den Start zu bringen.
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung nicht vergessen da können wir hoffen.
Das inzwischen die Führerschaft Logbuch Netzpolitik überdurchschnittlich gut geschützt ist und das doch schon mal schön.
Komme jetzt zum Zoo in Politik.
Genau letzte Sendung schon angekündigt ne dass die die die AFD wird geprüft vom bfvs.
Genau gut so.
Zeit wird's jetzt wo man das wohl offensichtlich nicht länger verzögert bekommt tut sich ein bisschen was nicht im ausreichenden Maße aber immerhin,
was passiert es gab halt ein Gutachten auf Basis dessen halt jetzt beschlossen wird das die AFD doch oder wo jetzt geprüft wird ob den sie jetzt auch wirklich beobachtet werden soll.
Dieses Gutachten ist jetzt gelegt worden bei niemand anderem als unseren Freunden von Netzpolitik.
Punkt Arktis einfach mal komplett instead.
Ergebnis des Gutachtens ist es wird vorgeschlagen die AFD zu beobachten und jetzt muss man natürlich überlegen was sind die unterschiedlichen,
also was ist der Unterschied zwischen prüffall Beobachtung.
Und ich glaube dass der Unterschied besteht darin welche Methoden die dann auch zur zur Verfügung haben.
Um Informationsgewinnung vorzunehmen.
Bei dieser Prüfung mussten sie im Handel sich im Prinzip auf die Internetauftritte öffentliche Äußerungen und so das was man irgendwie was man eben finden kann bei der Beobachtung.
Wären auch geheimdienstliche Mittel zulässig.
Wird Edith wohl finden wir bei netzpolitik.org dieser Flügel wird vom Verfassungsschutz also dieser rechtsextreme Flügel
den sie tatsächlich der Flügel nennt der wird vom Verfassungsschutz im Zuge des Gutachtens als sogenannter Verdachtsfall deklariert und all beim Verdacht Fall dürfen sie dann auch geheimdienstliche Mittel verwenden ich glaube bei Beobachtung nicht also gibt's prüffall Beobachtungs Fall Verdachtsfall,
diese Einstufung ist also nicht irrelevant auch für die Mittel die das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz hier nutzen darf interessant finde ich wie,
worauf dieses dieses Gutachten hauptsächlich basiert also sie haben gesagt sie haben sich primär auch Internetauftritte angeschaut.
Und haben die Facebook Profile von etwa 80 Partei funktionieren analysiert,
und irgendwie AFD junge Alternative Flügel patriotische Plattform und so weiter.
Und dieser ich glaube was war das 400 Seiten oder so dieses 400 Seiten Dokument hat 965 Quellenangaben Gala daran darunter allein 379 mal Facebook.
Also immer wieder Facebook Facebook Facebook und da,
schreiben an unsere Kollegen bei netzpolitik.org auch keine im Bundestag vertretene Partei hat so viele Anhänger in den sozialen Netzwerken wie die AFD.
Sie hat dort mehr Fans als CDU und SPD zusammen die Spitzenpolitiker liegen regelmäßig in Rankings ganz vorne
die Postings von Partei und funktionieren bekommen viele Interaktionen Facebook ist die kommunikative Hauptschlagader,
dieser Partei und das ist.
Sag mal vorsichtig nicht unbedingt überraschend dass das bei einer neuen verhältnismäßig neuen Partei der Fall ist nichtsdestotrotz ist das natürlich.
Problematischer aber.
Ich denke man bei der AFD auch wenn das eine alte Leute Partei ist musste sie trotzdem unter.
Den Gegebenheiten des 21 jahrhunderts sich Gründen bewerben und so weiter und das ist ihr offenbar entsprechend gelungen.
Warum finde ich das so ja also es macht da mit so einem größeren Block Block mit CK auf.
Welche Rolle spielen denn.
Diese sozialen Netzwerke in der politischen Willensbildung und in der politischen Information.
Unserer Bürgerinnen.
Und Bürger und Wahlberechtigten und so weiter wir haben ja viele verschiedene Phänomene Himmelsphänomen fake-news wollte gesagt wird der werden Unwahrheiten behauptet die verbreiten sich in den sozialen Netzwerken wir haben.
Was ich für das größere Problem halte die Zielgruppen gerichtete Werbung in diesen sozialen Netzwerken ja dass man also quasi sagen kann ich hätte ich würde gerne
männliche Personen weißer Hautfarbe zwischen 25 und 30 ansprechen die sich für
folgende YouTube Kanäle interessieren oder die sich für folgende Produkte interessieren
und den würde ich gerne folgende Werbung zeigen während ich weiblichen.
Dunkelhäutigen Person eine andere Werbung präsentieren möchte und so quasi zielgruppenorientiert werben kann oder auch eben.
Quasi Anti Verben kann ne also wie wir uns immer wieder erinnern die Wahl 2016 in den USA Wahl 2016.
Ja genau Amtseinführung 2017 also November 2016.
Entscheidende Strategie der republikanischen Partei war Nichtwähler zu gewinnen sondern dafür zu sorgen dass Hillary Clinton Wähler verliert.
Ja weil also das war einfach die die Bären Strategie und wenn man sich anschaut wie das
wie die Wahlen in den USA über die Jahre entschieden werden scheinen die Republikaner einfach grundsätzlich über so einem Plateau an Wählerinnen und Wählern zu verfügen.
Welches relativ gleichbleibend ist Wahlen bei den Demokraten haben anziehen mehr Fluktuation und über diese Fluktuation ob die Leute wählen gehen.
Gewinnen die Republikaner oder verlieren die Republikaner die Wahl.
Genau da gibt's ja verschiedene Methoden wie man Leute von der Wahl abhalten kann die klassischen sind halt so höhere Prüfsteine um die Leute überhaupt sich erstmal registrieren lassen zu können und dann zusätzliche ID Jakes
ja was soll ich denn aus Dakota haben sie es ja jetzt gerade probiert mit wir brauchen da mal eine richtige Adresse die irgendwo eintragen musst was z.b. die Indianer in den Reservaten so nicht haben etc.pp aber mit face
bruckwirt natürlichen komplett neues Kapitel aufgeschlagen weil man eben die Leute auch dazu motivieren kann so nach dem Motto hier Hillary Clinton die ist ja was weiß ich so und so wie du es nicht magst und
das kann ja nicht deine Wahl sein geh mal besser nicht wählen dass es sozusagen denn die Folge davon lassen,
haben Sie wahrscheinlich sowohl nicht explizit gesagt aber darauf ist es halt ausgelegt und beim brexit ist es ja ganz ähnlich genau.
Da konntest du zum Beispiel die Republikaner konnten auch sehr schön darauf bauen wie jetzt irgendwie diese eindeutig nicht Fähren,
Vorgehensweisen im Democratic National Council gegenüber Bernie Sanders waren ja die konnten also z.b. eine sinnvolle Strategie war Defenders Anhänger,
möglichst wütend und Clinton feindlich zu halten dass die am Ende nicht zur Wahl gehen ja wenn das Anhänger wählt niemals Donald Trump,
ja das wird einfach nicht passieren aber eventuell kriegst du einen seine das Anhänger davon abgehalten Hillary Clinton zu wählen.
Und das ist natürlich von der Wahlkampfstrategie eine sehr viel eine sehr viel sinnvollere Herangehensweise zu sagen er wir versuchen jetzt aus dem seine das wlan Trump Fehler zu machen
ist sehr viel weniger tiefer tiefer sprechen als zu sagen wir arbeiten jetzt daran dass die Sender svehla die Wahl boykottieren.
Und damit Hillary Clinton stimmen Kosten.
Uns aber nicht lange lange Rede kurzer Sinn soziale Netzwerke haben viele viele Möglichkeiten der Einflussnahme wir diskutieren in der Gesellschaft viele die Frage ist wer,
relevant und welche werden sinnvoll erfaßt zunächst einmal würde ich aber gerne darauf auf die Charmeoffensive von Mark Zuckerberg eingehen.
Der.
Wohlgemerkt du sprichst von charme und nicht von Scham.
Ich kam mit ech das ist auch ein schöner sein und übrigens.
Die Charmeoffensive.
Shazam ICH Scharmützel der.
Hat jetzt also einen offenen Brief geschrieben den REWE als Facebook Post veröffentlicht hat er wurde dann irgendwie von ZEIT-Online veröffentlicht und von.
Von Wallstreet Schorle und so weiter indem ihr irgendwie so schreibt ja SWR so also vor 15 Jahren ungefähr nächsten Monat wird Facebook 15.
Hätte er ja diese diese dieses Ding gegründet und es sei ihm von,
schon immer darum gegangen den umfassenden Austausch von Menschen zu ermöglichen der Zweck unseres Dienstes wird besteht darin Menschen zu helfen mit Familie Freunden und Gemeinschaften in Kontakt zu bleiben,
das ist gut das war ja vorher nicht möglich ne weißt du noch Tim vor 15 Jahren als wir immer unsere Familien verloren haben
und auf einmal allein auf der Welt waren und mich mehr mit unseren Freunden kommunizieren konnten weil wir nur Internet hatten und noch nicht Facebook das war dieser schreckliche Zeiten Tim weißt du das noch,
meine Güte war das tragische da mussten wir im Internet versuchen Leute zu finden.
Dieter Eck zum Glück haben von Facebook und hat uns hat uns das ermöglicht.
Also man muss sagen er hatte auch einen Punkt ja also ich denke schon dass das hat sich nicht das Feature ist was am Anfang die Leute auch wirklich zu Facebook gebracht hat ganz ehrlich.
Also,
erstmal erzählt dieses Facebook gestartet hatte hat er doch ursprünglich war das doch so ein so ein seine ursprüngliche Idee war doch irgendwie Menschen nach.
Tindaya.
So und irgendwie zu sagen er die Leute sind alle so hässlich hier ich baue eine Plattform wo wo ihr sehen könnt wie hässlich die alle sind ja und also das ist wirklich eine.
Schon eine sehr schöne sehr euphemistische Schilderung dessen was er da vor 15 Jahren für eine Version hatte
ich glaube dass jeder und jeder eine Stimme haben und in der Lage sein sollte sich mit anderen auszutauschen um dieses Ziel eine Plattform für alle umzusetzen braucht man einen Dienst die sich jeder leisten kann der beste Weg besteht darin die Leistung von Facebook kostenfrei anzubieten
durch Werbung ist dies möglich tja da bin ich ja jetzt mal.
Da bin ich mal etwas skeptisch ja denn würde Facebook seine Milliarden Nutzer.
Auch nur sagen wir mal so was wie 0,01% ihres monatlichen Einkommens Kos
kosten was ich dann immer noch jede Person leisten könnte dann hätte Facebook immer noch größere Umsätze als es jetzt haben ja also das ist eine nicht unbedingt so
philanthropische Einstellung die Facebook da hat und.
Er erkennt dann immerhin an dass das tracking bei Facebook sehr umfassend ist
und sagt er das würde aber zu unserer eigenen Sicherheit passiert ja dass die das dass wir quasi auf Facebook
getrackt werden und die möglichst alle unsere Schritte die wir tun ob wir jetzt irgendwie auf eine Werbeanzeige reagieren oder nicht dass das alles zu unserer Sicherheit wäre damit Facebook nachher
und Fake-Profile löschen kann ja das ist doch schön das hat natürlich nichts damit zu tun dass Facebook bei einer Konversion.
Sehr viel mehr Geld bekommt als bei der einfachen Anzeige einer Werbung nein nein das passiert alles nur,
zu unserem Schutz außerdem was ich auch besonders perfide fand er stellt sich dann da also Freund der klein und mittelständischen.
Und sagt mehr als 90 Millionen kleine Unternehmen nutzen Facebook und sie machen.
Großen ein Großteil unseres Geschäfts aus der rühmt der sich noch mit dass er quasi die kleinen und mittelständischen Unternehmen abschrift.
Statt nur für die großen zu arbeiten ja also das auch das finde ich das ist alles sehr sehr verquer zu lesen und eigentlich schwer nachvollziehbar warum leben
mehr Plattform gegeben wird als er mit seinem scheiß Facebook da hat in dadurch dass man diese offenen Briefe dann auch noch auf Zeit online und dem Original,
Abdruck immerhin auch mit Entgegnungen Auszeit online ist dann gleichzeitig eine eine Kritik,
dieses dieses Briefes oder eine Seite mal eine gerade eine Richtigstellung des Briefes erfolgt weil er darauf sagt er würde er wäre bereit das Facebook reguliert würde
und das ist natürlich totaler Unsinn denn er Facebook kämpft ja seit jeher.
Gegen die eigene Regulierung ja die haben Lobbyisten überall in jedem Gespräch mit der EU-Kommission haben sie immer gesagt wir brauchen keine Regulierung wir brauchen keine Regulierung,
denn Regulierung würde Innovation verhindern dass antworten Sie egal ob sie auf Fake News angesprochen werden,
auf Wahlmanipulation oder auf hate speech jedes Mal saß die Facebook Lobbyist da Sachen bitte bitte nicht regulieren denn wir wir können das mit unserer Innovation.
Selber in den Griff kriegen.
Ist natürlich auch über die Frage was versteht man unter Regulierung na das eine ist wir schränken euch mal in eurem treiben eine wie z.b. durch die datenschutz-grundverordnung und setzen hier einfach Mindeststandards an dir euch einfach halten muss,
womit dann bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr möglich sind aber das ist
natürlich die die Form von Regulierung an die wir zuerst denken die andere Form der Regulierung ist das was wir jetzt gerade sehen
hiermit den Upload filtern ja reguliert mal schön dass das dass unser Treiben hier zum Standard wird wo die anderen sowieso nicht mithalten können also
das ist so bisschen doppelsprech in echt.
Also diese diese diese andere diese zweite ist fängt die Regulierung das ist ja ich denke,
auch also ein so ein Grundgesetz des Kapitalismus und Häschen oder ein Naturgesetz ist Kapitalismus ich glaube auch sehr gut beschrieben wenn ich mich nicht täusche in the master Switch von tim,
wenn ich da jetzt nicht gerade die Bücher verwechseln wo auch gesagt wird im Prinzip wenn.
Wenn Konzerne erstmal eine marktbeherrschende Stellung haben dann freuen die sich Überregulierung,
weil die Regulierung Markteintrittsbarrieren für Konkurrenten darstellt und letztendlich wenn du einmal marktbeherrschend bist die Regulierung sehr häufig zur Zementierung deiner marktbeherrschenden Stellung beitragen kann
und das scheint mir inzwischen bei Facebook auch der Fall zu sein.
Genau das.
Aber was machen sie da kommen wir jetzt zu,
2 Maßnahmen von YouTube und Facebook die.
Die unangenehmen Phänomene der sozialen Netzwerke in irgendeiner Form einschränken sollen dem vorweg,
ich denke das Kernproblem nur um das noch mal zu betonen ist dass Facebooks Einnahmequelle Werbung ist und dass Facebook zielgerichtete Werbung ermöglicht,
das und und alle sozialen Netzwerke das ist ja der Grund warum die innerhalb kürzester Zeit.
Diese die die Werbeetats in den anderen Bereichen so so haben sinken lassen also früher hast du eine Anzeige in der Zeitung geschaltet oder irgendwann Poster plakatiert du hattest keinerlei Möglichkeiten zu messen.
Ob dieses Poster jetzt erfolgreich war wie viel dir das gebracht hat oder nicht mit Google Facebook und sonstigen Anbietern.
Kannst du ganz genau sagen ich möchte nicht nur dass dieses Poster in dem jüngeren Teil der Stadt aufgehängt wird sondern ich möchte dass das Poster nur genau der von mir definierten Zielgruppe angezeigt wird und ich kann nachher ganz genau sehen.
Wie viele von denen ich tatsächlich angesprochen habe man kann also eine sehr evidenzbasierte Werbung schalten.
Zielgruppenorientiert das ist das entscheidende Mann hat jetzt nicht mehr nur eine Zielgruppe sondern potentiell so viele Zielgruppen wie man möchte und dieses dieses Instrument der Macht.
Gibt Facebook an jeden der Farben will und der Geld dafür hat ja und das fanden wir eben ich sag mal von von 12 Jahre von Facebook Existenz total witzig.
Bis dann auf einmal jemand klar wurde ach scheiße das funktioniert ja auch im politischen Bereich.
Und dann wurde uns auf einmal Clara das könnt ihr ein Problem sein vorher wenn du es nur die richtigen Schuhe angeboten werden dann fand wir das immer total großartig und an diesen,
Kernproblem von von all diesen kostenlos und Erbe basierten Geschäftsmodellen ändern die Maßnahmen die jetzt von Google und.
Facebook eingerichtet wurden überhaupt nichts das wollte ich nur schonmal vorher.
Okay na dann guck mal noch mal was für Maßnahmen hier überhaupt ergriffen wurden fängt an,
mit YouTube YouTube hat also ist ja ein
Google Konzern hat natürlich ähnliche Probleme mit Fake News Verbreitung und hat jetzt angekündigt
dass sie Maßnahmen ergreifen wollen gegen virale Fake News
und auch ganz konkret gegen diese verschwörungs Videos Verschwörungstheorien die in Videos halt immer wieder neu unterfüttert werden nine-eleven und irgendwie die flache Erde und all dieser ganze Mumpitz das sind wohl
Dinge die die Runde machen und wo halt die Algorithmen von YouTube verstärkend wirken.
Was hat das für ein impact also auf der Homepage von YouTube wenn man sich da ein lockt mit seinem Account dann kriegt man ja so Empfehlung.
Und diese Empfehlungen basieren halt oft einfach auf anderen populären Videos die einem vielleicht gefallen
könnte denn was ja die Plattform möchte ist dass du dort verweilt dass du dir halt irgendwie Nacht für Nacht dich von Video zu Video durch Tanks weil umso mehr du auf dieser Oberfläche dieser Plattform bist umso mehr Werbung kannst du zur Kenntnis nehmen umso mehr Geld
verdient YouTube damit Größenordnung 200000000 Videos werden pro Tag von YouTube über die Homepage,
empfohlen also für alle Mensch zweihundert unterschiedlicher Millionen unterschiedliche Videos mich das richtig deute.
Leider steckt natürlich ein Algorithmus mal versucht er ist irgendwie rauszufinden und früher war es mal für das rauszufinden was was könnte interessant sein ne Vergleich mit der eigenen history ab was hat mich mir bisher angeschaut was interessiert mich was interessiert mich.
Nicht aber dann eben vor allem was ist denn dann in diesem Segment auch populär und am Anfang haben sich dann halt schnell auf so
dingl Wiener okay hier das haben sich schon so viele Leute angeschaut das muss ja toll sein was hat sich automatisch alles was schon mal so ein bisschen Verbreitung gefunden hat
neu beschleunigt hat das wurde dann über die Zeit angepasst und likes und dislikes wurden mit rein gebracht und nicht nur hier ist wie viel views an auf wie viel Verweildauer das ist also nicht nur wie viel Leute haben angefangen da und wir einzuknicken sonnwies Landau,
signifikant Zeit mit verbracht all diese ganzen Dinge sind mir eingeschlossen,
hat aber allerdings nicht unbedingt dazu geführt dass Quatsch nicht weiterhin nach oben gespült wird
naja und jetzt möchten sie halt ganz gerne gegen diesen Borderline konnten wie sie das nennen oder
Videos die einen inmis informieren könnten Vorgehen ja also bitte den der verschwörungs unseren gibt's ja auch echte Probleme hiermit Wunderheilungen und Homöopathie wenn du Krebs hast dann hilft das hier und nimmt dieses Mittelchen etc es gibt aber eine ganze Menge lustigerweise ist
sie meinen in ihrer Pressemitteilung naja das würde ja auch nur weniger als 1% der Videos betreffen ich mir dachte so wow.
Hit Prospekt.
Einprozenter YouTube-Videos ist mehr als du gucken kannst.
Bei 0,1 oder so würde ich ja schon die braunen aber irgendwie ein Prozent das echt ne ganze Menge.
Keine Ahnung ob sie jetzt geglaubt haben dass diese Zahl irgendwie,
beschwört wirken nicht man erkennt das ja so von der Telekom ja wieso denn unsere unsere Leitungen funktioniert ja auch in 99% der Fälle also wie du.
Kriegen doch 1000 km.
Nee also ich werde so 99% Zuverlässigkeit klingt ja erstmal super heiß auf das Date wird Leitung auch 3 Tage ja,
so schön ist das jetzt nicht also ich hoffe mal der hat sich nur einer vertippt und die Zahl der Videos liegt deutlich niedriger ist aber auf jeden Fall
Zoo.
Jetzt wollen wir also das widiger bewerben sprich es geht jetzt hier nicht um eine Löschung das geht nur darum dass dieser empfehlungs Algorithmus möglichst diesen ganzen Quatsch außen vor lässt
und ja wie könnte es denn anders sein wie geht man denn jetzt hier ran um diese.
Schöne neue Welt zu bescheren Mama nimmt hat eine Schienen learning kombiniert mit,
wieso das so schön denn human evaluators
also sie holt Dich da Leute die halt sich im Prinzip diese ganzen Schmutz anschauen müssen das Prinzip
das Problem haben sie ja jetzt auch schon und die sollen da sozusagen raus zu diktieren ok ist das Unsinn oder ist das nicht.
Also es gibt jetzt eine eine Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Genau also das Problem haben das Problem bei machine learning das hatten wir glaube ich auch schon öfter mal angeschnitten ist ja
machine learning ist ist im Prinzip mit eine Taufe Technologie aber du musst trotzdem um diesen Trainings Vorgang erfolgreich zu machen irgendwie eine Wahrheit Quelle haben und
welldone uns fährt mal diese Wiese noch mal Thai glaube ich ne von Microsoft dieses.
Teil was ich auf Twitter gewagt hatte und sich dann quasi von Twitter hat weiter trainieren lassen ja wo das Ding dann innerhalb von 24 Stunden zu sinnvollen hat sie geworden ist.
Ja ich glaube das geht also ich ich halte dieses das für eine lösbare Aufgabe,
also wenn du in der Inventur innerhalb eines Tages in Twitter bot zum Nazi kriegst dann wirst du ja wohl irgendwie so eine YouTube gucken der irgendwie innerhalb von eines Tages zum 1A dr Axel Stoll werden lassen.
Ja sicher nicht also es kann halt in jede Richtung gehen mit anderen Worten es hängt halt hochgradig davon ab
was diese jungen evaluate hast du meinen Indira evaluation also im Prinzip können die auch genau in die andere Richtung marschieren
bitte also die Truppe von flach Erdland dahin setzt dann ist halt YouTube Stunden und brauchbare.
Bilder des blauen Planeten Verschwörungstheorie.
Okay jetzt erstmal die sagen okay alles klar YouTube tut mal was aber das andere Loch was wir uns natürlich dann hier potentiell
zum reinfallen vorbereiten ist natürlich wieder ok Wer erzeugt denn jetzt hier die Wahrheit also welches Expertengremium ist denn jetzt hier quasi zuständig hier Klarheit zu schaffen weil natürlich
wissen wir alle okay so flache Erde und so und das Mark ist noch relativ,
einfach abzufangen sein ne aber im Prinzip kann halt dieselbe Technologie und wird diese selbe Technologie auch auf Dinge angewendet werden die in irgendeiner Form politisch
fragwürdig ist oder politisch unterschiedliche Meinung zum Ausdruck bringt gut das,
Problem hatten wir von Anfang an das wird dadurch jetzt nicht unbedingt besser muss man aber im Hintergrund Hinterkopf behalten.
Also.
Die Idee das jetzt bei YouTube,
unbedingt flach erdler oder Trump Leute diese diese Prüfung machen würden halte ich für erstmal jetzt nicht dass das wahrscheinlichste bitte.
Das wollte ja mit das wollte ich damit auch nicht sagen ich wollte nie wollte nur damit sagen man hat jetzt hier quasi ein Gremium was versucht das Richtige zu tun ja nur was definiert halt langfristig.
Das richtige ja also wer wer kontrolliert die Kontrolle.
Ja also,
ja also ich denke das Entscheidende ist hier.
Die bei diesen Empfehlungen ist so ein bisschen also ich glaube das ist eine relativ sinnvolle Möglichkeit ist dort anzusetzen ja weil.
Diese Empfehlungen.
Teilweise eben in so in so doofe Richtungen gehen ja und es ist schon nicht verkehrt zu sagen ok wenigstens unsere unser
guck doch mal weiter System ja soll die Leute jetzt nicht auch noch an die Verschwörungstheorien heranführen.
Der andere Maßnahmen werden wir verbieten die wir machen jetzt hin so oder sonst was und hier gibt es jetzt nur in dem empfehlungs Algorithmus,
jetzt eine Kontrolle Kontrollmöglichkeit unter Kontrolle Option zusagen,
wenigstens führen wir die Leute jetzt nicht noch an die flacherdler und Infokrieger und sonstige unseriöse Personen ran und ich würde gerne einen. Auf jeden Fall noch machen.
Also Verschwörungstheorie ist ist natürlich so ein vorsichtiger so ein so ein problematischer Bereich weil der Verschwörungstheorien sind in der Regel.
Unsinnige Behauptungen die auch nicht aufgrund der Faktenlage.
Widerlegt werden können ja die gehen immer also jedes jedes.
Gegenbeispiele jedes Indiz und jeder fakte gegen die Verschwörungstheorie spricht wird dann automatisch als in irgendeiner Form fabriziert gefälscht von der CIA bereitgestellt diskreditiert ja,
Verschwörungstheoretiker erheben Behauptungen und Anschuldigung ohne einen einzigen.
Einen einzigen Beleg oder ein einziges belastbares Indiz dafür zu zeigen.
Außer dass alle anderen belastbaren Indizien genau die andere Richtung zeigen gefälscht seien.
Ja das ist das sind Mechanismen und ein Muster die sind als die sind einfach erkennbar ja also die sind,
definierbar und die sind auch überprüf,
ja und wenn du dir solche Verschwörungstheoretiker anguckst die haben ein spezifisches Repertoire an Argumentationen die sie vortragen
ja das ist immer ewig ja das ist aber im Interesse des Mossad und so weiter die sind und,
und sonstige Schutzbehauptung sind einfach zu fälschen gewesen ja insofern glaube ich schon dass es.
Dass man das sinnvoll erkennen kann was eine Verschwörungstheorie ist und was nicht und ich halte es auch nicht für so blöd diese Idee mit den mit dem fact checking und so die wir bis jetzt selten sinnvoll realisiert gesehen haben.
Die aber grundsätzlich schon.
Ja halbwegs funktionieren könnte davon unberührt bleibt aber natürlich der grundsätzliche.
Die grundsätzliche Anspruch den ich immer der Vollständigkeit halber wiederholen möchte das Filtern von was irgendwie.
Glaubwürdig und ernsthaft und was Unsinn ist muss in eurem Kopf stattfinden jegliche Form der Bevormundung ist hier grundsätzlich erst einmal abzulehnen das heißt aber nicht.
Dass jegliche Form der Korrektur und der Einschätzung die andere Leute für euch vornehmend abzulehnen falls abzulehnen ist ihr müsst der der der Filter muss in eurem eigenen Kopf sein und dieser Filter muss.
Trainiert sein und der muss durch Bildung trainiert sein und der muss durch im sei mal im weitesten Sinne wissenschaftliches und.
Aufgeklärtes und journalistisches Denken trainiert und.
Das ist irgendwie das was leider leider leider in dieser Debatte immer so ein bisschen.
Unter die Räder kommen und zwar in beiden Seiten ja sie einerseits die Leute die auf so einen Mist
rein fallen dir die denken denn jede Form der der Kontrolle Hilfe ihren Armen Seelen irgendwie ein bisschen unter die Arme zu greifen.
Bei der informations Einschätzung wird dann sofort als bösartige Zensur Maßnahme gesehen während,
andererseits natürlich auch tatsächlich das Risiko des ausnutzen es als Zensur Maßnahme besteht insofern natürlich wollen wir solche Filter nicht aber wir wir wollen sie nicht weil wir hoffen dass Sie Filter in euren Köpfen sind.
Und leider sind die nicht in jedem Kopf.
Ja also ich wollte jetzt auch nicht sagen dass das von sich aus ne schlechte Idee ist das zu tun ich glaube es bleibt ihnen in der derzeitigen Situation auch relativ wenig übrig als das so zu realisieren
wie gut so komplexe Dinge wie die Bewertung von Wahrheit sich durch machine learning letzten Endes auch wirklich Appel es bleibt abzuwarten sie wollen das ganze jetzt erstmal in den USA ausprobieren und wenn es denn dann funktioniert weltweit ausdehnen
ich würde mal sagen USA besteht doch gerade der größte Bedarf aber ich hoffe das kommt dann auch schnell nach Britannien.
Okay komm wir zur neu eingeführten Maßnahme bei Whatsapp ein Unternehmen der Facebook Gruppe.
Die mussten sich dem Phänomen,
Indien ist zu letzter Zeit regelmäßig zu lynchmorde kam ja da wurden.
Fake News über WhatsApp Gruppen verbreitet und zwar dass es sich bei bestimmten Personen irgendwie um Kinder Kindesentführer,
handeln würde und dann wurden ihr die Videos von diesem Menschen verbreitet über whatsapp,
und einige der betroffenen Personen wurden sogar zu Tode geprügelt 420,
lynchmorde soll es im vergangenen Jahr in Indien gegeben haben aufgrund,
dieses Phänomens Indien hilflos hat dann irgendwie Werbung geschaltet und irgendwie Menschen versucht darauf aufmerksam zu machen dass Sie bitte nicht jeden Scheiß glauben dass der der ihn
Dänin irgendjemand über WhatsApp geschickt hat das Problem in diesem Fall bei Whatsapp war das.
Die Kommunikation ja nicht öffentlich stattfindet und WhatsApp sogar verschlüsselt ist so dass die Inhalte nicht ohne weiteres einsehbar waren das heißt wir hatten hier so ein virales Phänomen was,
fernab der Öffentlichkeit in eben privaten
Gruppen stattfand und sogar hier sich einer inhaltlichen Kontrolle zwecks Analyse oder Eindämmung oder sonstigen entzogen hat was.
Grundsätzlich gut ist
ja es ist gut dass es solche Kommunikationsmittel gibt es ist natürlich sehr schlecht wenn sich mit diesem Kommunikationsmitteln Methoden
oder oder Situationen ergeben bei denen Menschen zu Tode kommen Grundproblem ist hier bleibt bleibe ich bei die.
Mangelnde Kompetenz der Menschen im Umgang mit solchen.
Beschuldigungen aber wir müssen.
Auch einsehen dass das immer wieder der Fall ist gerade auch in den USA wieder sehr schön.
Wann war das letzte woche dieser Fall zwischen diesen Schülern und den.
Native Americans und dieser islamischen radikalen Gruppe
am Washington Memorial war das glaube ich dir dann irgendwie nach und nach aus verschiedenen Kameraperspektiven gezeigt wurde und sich daneben auch unterschiedliche Bilder ergeben haben ja und alle sahen immer
zunächst einmal ihre eigene Weltanschauung bestätigt ja und das ist natürlich ein grundsätzlicher Effekt.
Der Psyche der Menschen mit dem BMI umgehen müssen okay was hat face was hat WhatsApp gemacht denn gesagt na ja um derartiges viral gehen und irgendeiner Form einzuschränken
in seiner exponentialität begrenzen wir.
Die Anzahl an Personen an die man eine Nachricht weiterleiten kann von vormals 20 auf 5 Personen.
Ja das war also diese diese WhatsApp Dinger waren also immer so leite dieses dieses Video oder diesen Aufruf an an alle weiter und dann haben die Leute konnten die Leute aufheben bis zu 20.
Personen weiterleiten und jetzt sind es halten bis zu 5 Personen ich bin mal gespannt ob das jetzt.
Eine eine sinnvolle Einschränkungen dieses Phänomens zur Folge hat aber vielleicht ist es grundsätzlich nicht blöd ein Messenger der ja einer.
Gezielten Kommunikation in vorher definierten Gruppen oder zwischen Individuen.
Dienen soll und dafür konzeptioniert wurde da in irgendeiner Form.
Sag ich mal die Funktion der exponentiellen Weiterleitung und Verbreitung von Informationen irgendwie einzuschränken.
Ja also diese diese Funktion nicht unbedingt prominent in den Messenger zu haben halte ich grundsätzlich auch für gut weil das.
Diese diese messenger dann halt auch nutzbar hält ja also wenn ich wenn ich irgendwie öffentlich relevante Informationen haben will dann kann ich mir die irgendwie offen Blog
bei Facebook oder auf Twitter anschauen und wenn ich in einer Kleingruppe eine Abstimmung machen möchte dann kann ich das eben mit einem messenger tun und ich halte es sinnvoll.
Den Messenger Messenger sein zu lassen und die Öffentlichkeiten öffnen gleichzeitig glaube ich aber nicht dass das Phänomen.
Sich dadurch eindämmen lässt ob jetzt im ob der Exponent jetzt ob wir ob jetzt 20 Personen oder fünf Personen informieren kannst das sollte ehrlich gesagt dass das Phänomen im Zweifelsfall nicht nicht sinnvoll einschränken,
können glaube ich also kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass.
Weil sie frage ich mich auch gerade über nachgedacht klar kann man sich sagen ok wenn dann die fünf auch wieder weiterleiten RC aber du,
einerseits degradiert du natürlich dieses Mittel von ich sage jetzt mal ganz vielen Bescheid Zurich
muss mir schon mehr darüber Gedanken machen welche fünf ich jetzt eigentlich nehme das so dass eine was soll kleinen Faktor spielen könnte und damit es daneben.
Überhaupt noch dieselbe Zahl an Menschen erreichen müssen halt noch mehr Leute auf diese Entscheidung treffen es weiterzureichen das heißt da fallen halt unter Umständen noch mal ein paar ebenen Weg aber das wird man am Ende nur sehen können wenn man halt diese,
Funktion qualitativ auswerten.
Und wenn ich das richtig verstehe ist das ein Filter der in der App ist ja also dass der kommt erst nach Update und ich glaube der bläst sich im Zweifelsfall so wieder beschrieben ist sehr einfach umgehen indem ich einfach die Nachricht kopiere und in irgend eine WhatsApp Gruppe mit mit 40 EmpfängerInnen Piste
ja also das ist wirklich nur die die Weiterleitungsfunktion von Whatsapp selber
die sie wohl offenbar hatten ja ich kann also hier redet der Blinde von der Farbe weil ich habe gar keine Kotze.
Du hast keine WhatsApp beruflich zu deine Nachrichten heller.
Ich gucke mir die an ich gehe da hin und guck aber,
diese ganzen diese ganzen aber das ist auch irgendwie ein Phänomen hier diesen Newsletter und so die ist jetzt wieder gibt ne und und WhatsApp Gruppen die die diese,
die Diesel Outlets jetzt aufmachen kenne ich alles nicht ist auch will ich auch nicht haben tschuldigung ich gehe noch ich bin noch ich ich kaufe mir zwar keine Zeitung aus Papier aber ich gehe immer noch hin und will nicht dass mein Handy Piep.
Naja komm jetzt zum dritten Themenbereich unschöne Phänomene in sozialen Netzwerken.
Vieldiskutiert der Einfluss von Bots.
Wer hier schon länger mithört weiß dass ich dazu ja auch im Bundestag glaube ich ein oder zweimal zur Anhörung war und dann bisschen was zu gesagt habe die.
Äußerung über die oder die Einschätzungen wie negativ Ports sind reichen von ein vernachlässigbares Phänomen bis Untergang jeglicher Zivilisation.
Untergang jeglicher Zivilisation ist öffentlichkeitswirksam besser zu vermarkten das heißt da hatten wir entsprechende Diskussionen drüber wunderschön.
Die vorletztes Jahr der Michael Krey mit seinem Vortrag.
Auf dem 34 C3 auseinandergenommen der ja auch übrigens ne mit Dank,
insbesondere an Euch liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer endet weil ihr diese Forschung ermöglicht habt durch das Spenden eurer Twitter.
Zugriff Sepia Account also der Vortrag noch mal zu dem Thema sehr.
Ans Herz gelegt jetzt gibt's eine wunderschöne Studie zum Thema Fake News wir haben auch hier war ja die.
Das dass die an die die die Sorge die an die Wand gemalt wurde ja es werden Unwahrheiten verbreitet.
Und das ist ein Fan ein einen eine Bedrohung der Demokratie weil dann bricht uns eine Grundannahme Weg nämlich das.
Die Menschen irgendwie faktenbasiert ihre Meinung.
Bilden ja und oder ihre Interessen bilden und die daneben der politischen Umsetzung zu führen in Form von,
politischen Meinung die sie vertreten und politischen Parteien die sie wählen und jetzt gibt es also hier dass das Phänomen das.
Unwahrheiten behauptet werden und in den sozialen Netzwerken Verbreitung finden.
Frage ist wie groß ist dieses Phänomen.
Und zweitens wie wirksam ist dieses Phänomen ist es tatsächlich so dass irgendein.
Alter Griesgram auf Facebook postet heute haben sie wieder auf dem Dorfplatz in Hammel geschächtet und danach 20 Frauen.
Dann lesen das Leute und saniert reichts AFD ja oder sind selbst AFD Leserin Wählerinnen und Wähler vielleicht ein bisschen.
Pizza in der Einordnung von ihren Informationen also vor allem die Frage lassen sich die Leute auch durch.
Diese Fake News manipulieren und manipulieren heißt in dem Fall dass sie danach etwas anderes denken oder etwas anderes tun als sie es vor dem Konsum dieser fake-news getan haben denn nur dann wäre das ja wirklich ein.
In dem Sinne Manu manipulatives Phänomen nun diese Studie erschienen in silence,
oder 11 erscheint läuft nächste Woche 11 oder diese Woche 11 die sind folgendermaßen vorgegangen dir gegangen die haben sich 16.000 Twitter Konten ausgewählt die zwischen August und Dezember 2016 aktiv an,
also genau um den Zeitbereich US-Wahl.
Die glaube ich am 9. September am 9. November war ne ja die haben dann die Nutzernamen.
Und die tatsächlichen Namen der Besitzer mit dem Wahlregister abgeglichen um sicherzustellen dass ich dabei auch um Personen handelt also hier umgekehrt nicht eine Studie an Bord sein eine Studie an Personen.
Und sie wollten wissen wie viele erfundene Geschichten diese Person in ihrem Newsfeed eingeblendet bekommen haben.
Wie sie überhaupt diese Nachrichten konsumieren und welchen gesellschaftlichen Gruppen sie angehört haben,
na und wollten also wissen okay haben die Fake News bekommen und wenn ja wie sind Sie damit umgegangen Ergebnis nur 1,12 bis 1,
24 Prozent der Tweets zu politischen Themen waren der Untersuchung zufolge überhaupt falschnachrichten ja also falschnachrichten sind ungefähr 1% dessen was die Leute an Tweets bekommen.
Und während des letzten Kampagnen Monats hätten die Wählerinnen in diesem twitter feed demnach zwischen 185 und 224 potenziell erfundene Geschichten sehen können,
im Zweifelsfall haben wir aber nicht den gesamten twitter feed gelesen sondern nur einen Teil davon so dass es im Schnitt vielleicht
10 Uhr gewesen sein weil die durchschnittliche Person nur 5% der Tweets überhaupt wahrnimmt.
All das übrigens zitiert von einem Artikel auf Zeit online von Lisa Hegemann die diese Studie.
Sehr gut zusammengefasst hat und dann stellt sich also heraus bei extrem rechts eingestellten Personen.
Führten 72% der links auf traditionelle Nachrichtenseiten bei extrem Links eingestellten waren es 86% der geteilten ORF.
Also.
An dem politischen an den beiden extrem Seiten des politischen Spektrums ist immer noch drei Viertel der Nachrichten bei den traditionellen Medienhäusern traditionell deshalb hier relevant weil die zur Vereinfachung und zur,
Kategorisierung ihre Plattform eingeteilt haben in ok Journalist isches Outlet das entsprechenden.
Hochqualitativen Kontrollen unterliegt dann,
journalistische Sound etwas im Prinzip kaputte qualitative Kontrollen hat und gerne auch mal Unsinn verbreitet da haben sie z.b. infowars eingeordnet und dann eben noch das Outlet was einfach grundsätzlich,
offenbar absichtlich und wieder bessere wider besseren Wissens Agyness in die Welt setzt also diese drei Kategorisierung hatten sie.
Das heißt eine relativ großzügige Einsortierung wo sich infowars nur als Outlet mit mit defizitären fact-checking kategorisiert.
Finde dann die anderen.
So und.
Dann haben sie gesagt ob die Leute das jetzt auch noch selbst verbreitet haben also genau dieser virale Effekt ja also nicht nur haben wir es bekommen sondern sie geben es weiter.
Ja das hängt vor allem und da sehe ich mich in allen bestätigt was ich bisher gesagt habe von der politischen Einstellung ab die die Personen schon vorher hatten
weniger als 5% der Menschen links oder in der Mitte des politischen Spektrums verbreiteten fake-news weiter bei den rechts oder extrem rechts eingestellten Personen waren es 11 % bzw 21%
was heißt das unterm Strich wir neigen dazu unsere Position und Einstellungen festzuhalten.
Das heist ob jemand Fake News verbreitet.
Sagt primär etwas über die Einstellung dieser Person aus und hat viel weniger Einfluss darauf ob nun andere Personen.
Aufgrund auf Basis dieser Fake News nur sagen ich ändere meine Meinung
und das erklärt auch wiederum lange Schluss dieses diese enthemmte Kommunikation der AFD Vertreter auf Facebook weil sie da eben unter sich.
Noch mal das auch noch mal sagen dürfen na das wird man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen Gruppen auf Facebook und.
Das ist auch relativ kongruent mit allen anderen Forschungsergebnissen von Jahrzehnten Psychologie das ist sehr sehr viel schwieriger ist und sehr sehr viel mehr braucht als vielleicht ein Tweet oder eine Fake News um Menschen.
In ihren politischen Einstellungen.
Oder auch nicht um den politischen Einstellungen zu ändern also eine Meinung einer Person zu ändern ist sehr.
Schwierig die Meinung einer Person zu bestätigen ist sehr einfach so heißt das vollständige Entwarnung für Fake News,
nein nicht unbedingt es ist immernoch alarmierend dass wir Bevölkerungsgruppen haben die inzwischen soweit sind dass sie jeden Stoß glauben.
Ich habe das mal habe ich auch hier in der Sendung schon öfter mal zitiert ja die,
die haben ja auch Anlass dazu egal in welchem Land gegenüber der politischen Klasse wenn man da mal so einen Fazit über sag mir mein Verlauf von 10 Jahren zieht durch auszusagen.
Die Behauptung dass die etwas Unwahres sagen oder dass die ihre Versprechen im Zweifelsfalle nicht halten dafür gibt es eine empirische Datenbasis.
Und deswegen glaube ich den nicht und ich glaube jetzt sogar ihr ne dass die Regierung LSD vom Himmel.
Schießt mit Flugzeugen als dass ich noch irgendetwas glaube was sagen aber die SPD zur Rettung des Sozialstaates sagt ja die haben ja auch ein Anlass,
so zu denken und das denke ich ist das hier viel größere und viel viel besorgniserregend darauf Phänomen nicht unbedingt,
mehr Verbreitung finden und dass Leute das Sehen und sein oh mein Gott jetzt werde ich aber AFD weil ne Hammel geschächtet oder was auch immer ja sondern,
dass wir inzwischen Bevölkerungsgruppen haben die soweit sind dass sie zur Bestätigung ihrer Einstellung so etwas heranziehen das noch nicht mal mehr in Frage stellen.
Und und sich da drin auch noch bestätigt sehen und daneben dieses Phänomen haben down the rabbit hole ja das heißt.
Eigentlich besorgniserregende Phänomen ist dass wir Menschen haben die so ein Scheiß glauben und das ist enorm schwer wird.
Mit mit solch mal Argumentationen Fakten und sonstigen diese Leute irgendwie noch mal in die Nähe der Spur zu bringen.
Also so würde ich zumindest diese diese Studie interpretieren das Problem ist nicht dass das,
immer das Fake News Verbreitung finden sondern das Fake News auf einen Nährboden fallen bei bestimmten Leuten die inzwischen offenbar leider so weit von der.
Von welchem einer rationalen Realität entfernen.
Aber es passt natürlich auch trotzdem mit dem was wir vorhin gesagt haben noch zusammen dass man sehr wohl eben selbst wenn jetzt nicht weiter geteilt wird,
nur oder die Meinung wird dich geändert wird es zumindest Leute sobald beeinflussen kann dass sie sagen können ok.
Also es kann es kann viel passieren mit diesen Leuten und wir werden uns Gedanken darüber machen wie wir die irgendwie wieder hin über die irgendwie wieder.
Gerade gerückt bekommen.
Wie war die gerade gerückt bekommen ja und gerade gerückt heißt hier erstmal nur.
Bevor das jetzt irgendwie hier als Gehirnwäsche Motivation raus gelegt wird gerade rücken heißt erstmal nur dass sie bitte.
Auf Basis von Tatsachen und Fakten und einer sinnvollen Einschätzung und Gewichtung dieser Tatsachen ihren Meinungsbildungsprozess durchführen,
die können am Ende immer noch dabei langen dass sie dann heißt denn dann eben FDP wählen ja
oder oder wen auch immer,
aber wenigstens auf Basis und unter Berücksichtigung der Fakten die machen den ganzen Quatsch ja nicht umsonst mit der Wissenschaft mit der Erforschung und mit dem Journalismus der relativ hohe
Qualitätsstandards hat und stets bemüht ist die auch einzuhalten.
Gut, machen wir weiter.
Wird Zeit für ein bisschen mehr Dystopia.
Ja ich find auch die Sendung ist viel zu da halt habe ich schon zu diesem Zeitpunkt viel zu positiv.
Kommt noch kommt noch.
Gerechter kommt auch was guck mal sag mal das Gesundheitswesen an da ist doch bestimmt alles in Ordnung.
Im Gesundheitswesen ist alles in Ordnung ja wie jeder weiß der Krankenkassenbeiträge Zoder in der Privatversicherung ist oder man krank daher.
Also was hat sich was hat sich was hat uns die Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen gebracht da was haben wir jetzt so schöne Sachen die haben gehen Datenbanken
wir haben Gesundheits-App und Gesundheits-App und wir haben,
IOT bei medizinal Geräten Assistent für Sachen die wir immer schon haben wollen wo man sich fragt wie wir sonst wie wir froh erst gesund wurden ohne sowas ne
was haben wir dadurch für schöne neue Phänomene.
Malware in Krankenhäusern ja schön dieses war noch auf wann war das denn 20/16 ne diese schönen Ransomware Infektionen in Krankenhäusern wo dann.
H&M in Neuss war dieses eine Krankenhaus in Deutschland und gibt ganz glaube ich zwei drei prominente Fälle in Deutschland.
Dann gabs noch diese wannacry Fall in Großbritannien wo einfach mal ich glaube 11 Krankenhäuser auf einen Schlag.
Wieder mit Stift und Papier gearbeitet haben und keinen Zugriff auf Ihre auf die Patientendaten hatten wo also,
mein relativ nah an bedroht lebensbedrohlichen Situationen für Menschenleben war,
das ist also jetzt eine an der soll ich mal dein schönes ein eines der Phänomene der Digitalisierung Gesundheitswesen dann.
Wie wir hier in Logbuch Netzpolitik ausführlich gesprochen haben Martin tschirsich hat sich die gesundheits-apps angeschaut und eigentlich bei jeder katastrophale Sicherheitslücken gefunden.
Noch dazu was der denke ich sehr viel spannendere oder der ebenso spannende Teil seines Vortrags ist.
Die Tatsache dass diese Unternehmen das einpreisen und quasi schon Einschätzung haben wie viele Daten sieht pro.
Zeiteinheit verlieren welche Schäden
ihnen dadurch entstehen durch Wiedergutmachung Strafzahlung und so weiter dass es quasi alles schon Teil des Geschäftsmodells ist und das irgendwann 2050 sowieso alle Gesundheitsdaten öffentlich sind wenn die so weitermachen.
Und dann jetzt kürzlich.
Das Promi doxing Phänomen was jetzt mal wieder allen gezeigt hat ach so scheiße Daten können öffentlich werden was machen wir denn dann mit Gesundheitsdaten.
Wenn das passiert also das ist ja jetzt dass das neue ja und jetzt jetzt kommen wir kombinieren wir mal hier unseren,
unsere doxing Sparten hier ne wenn die in der ganze in zehn Jahren gemacht hätten dann wäre auf jeden Fall bei dieser Anzahl Personen.
Von der ein oder anderen Person auch eine Gesundheitsakte dabei gewesen einfach also das einfach Gesetz der großen Zahlen wenn du so viele Leute Hack so viele Daten sammelt dann kommst du auch.
Wenn dann eben diese gesundheits-apps entsprechende Verbreitung gefunden haben an solche Gesundheitsdaten mit im Zweifelsfall Passwort 123.
Und Darm sich jetzt natürlich die Öffentlichkeit hat sich darüber Gedanken gemacht und vor allem natürlich auch die Chefs der unions Abgeordneten im Bundestag EU Parlament und Länderparlamenten die jetzt sagen aha.
Wenn dieses Risiko besteht wenn unsere Krankenhäuser abgeschossen werden wenn unsere persönlichen Daten hier veröffentlicht werden wenn der tschirsich sagt ist alles unsicher ja dann was ist die notwendige Konsequenz daraus,
ganz klar wir brauchen einen Notfallplan.
Um innerhalb kurzer Zeit auf den Abfluss sensibler Daten digitale Wirtschaftsspionage oder Sabotage reagieren zu können mit anderen Worten hack back.
Und wir brauchen härtere Strafen denn wir wissen härtere Strafen haben schon immer.
Verhindert ja und Sicherheitslücken verschwinden auch durch härtere Strafen Straftatbestände die verschwinden tatsächlich dadurch weil der Martin ja jetzt schon immer wieder.
Mit irgendwelchen
rechtlichen Auseinandersetzung nicht vor Gericht aber irgendwelche Anwälte die dann mal drohen oder hier irgendwelche Krisenmanager die auch mal persönlich anrufen und drohen zu tun hat das heißt Sicherheitsforschung findet immer in dieser rechtlichen Grauzone Stadt und klar wenn man da die Handschellen anzieht
dann werden Sicherheitslücken eben nur noch von Kriminellen ausgenutzt und nicht von interessierten Patienten.
Die sich hier um den Schutz unserer Daten bemühen also,
eine maximal dumme Forderung die mit dem Problem überhaupt nichts zu tun hat nämlich die Unsicherheit in diesem Bereich entsprechend gibt es demgegenüber eine Gruppe von IP Experten,
Datenschutzbeauftragten die einen offenen Brief an,
denke es ist immer schwierig das da stolpert die Zunge wenn man kurz noch mal denkt will kann doch gar nicht sein Gesundheitsminister Jens Spahn ich habe extra noch mal geguckt nichts Gesundheitsminister Jens Spahn ist Gesundheitszeugnis.
Na ja sei froh.
Dann sei froh dass er nicht was anderes ist.
Ich finde das wäre super Bäcker da würde ich morgens mein Bäcker in meine Brötchen holen bei mir einsparen hätte ich nichts gegen hier
diese diese diese Etiketten und Datenschutzbeauftragten wollen nach den jüngsten Vorkommnissen weiterführende Pläne gibt's natürlich auch noch ne denn als nächstes in der Digitalisierung kommt natürlich dann künstliche Intelligenz und so weiter.
Sie zeigen also hier die Risiken auf und sagen die Begeisterung über die Technik trübt den Beteiligten offenbar den Blick auf die Risiken,
wir müssen Flächen deckend systematisch und proaktiv investieren in Sicherheitskonzepte.
Natürlich auch notfalls Konzepte physikalischen Einbruchschutz elektronische Signaturen kryptografische Verschlüsselung identity Access Management und Security incident.
Ems emergency management systems rollenspezifische Bildung für alle herstellerunabhängige und nach Möglichkeit dynamische Gütesiegel für die für die Cloud sowie Produkte Dienstleistung Apps.
Penetrationstest also gefordert wird nichts anderes als eine sinnvolle rangeht.
Die diese Schutzmechanismen stärken soll denn die beste Verteidigung gegen Angriffe ist VAT ID.
Und nicht Gegenangriff und nicht härtere Strafen oder irgendwelcher Stoß sondern die Investition in Sicherheitskonzepte eine Regulierung die vernünftige Sicherheitskonzepte mandatiert.
Und die alles andere insbesondere den leichtfertigen Umgang mit unseren Daten wir irgendwie bei CGM life und bei Vivi und wie sie alle heißen einfach nachweisbar.
Und es ist nicht nachvollziehbar dass.
Das auf diese Weise politisch so leichtfertig mit diesem riesigen umgegangen wird und so inkompetent mit diesem riesigen umgegangen wird und ich bin sehr froh dass ich diesen Thema jetzt.
Die Ärztezeitung angeschlossen hat die dieses Thema relativ groß aufgehängt hat in ihrer aktuellen.
Ausgabe der diesen offenen Brief gefeatured hat verschiedene Interviews mit mit Martin in diesem Bereich geführt hat und hoffentlich hoffentlich hoffentlich ihre Interessengruppe der Mediziner.
Jetzt auch mit dem mit der entsperren Inkompetenz in entsprechenden Forderungen aus startet hier für eine Sicherheit der Patienten und Patientinnen zu sorgen das wäre sehr schön denn.
Also es ist ich finde es katastrophal wie nach solchen also nach Jahren.
Derartiger Phänomene.
Ausfälle Ausfall kritischer Infrastrukturen Ransomware Angriff auf ein Krankenhaus und das Krankenhaus kommt dann zum Erliegen das ist ein Ausfall kritischer Infrastruktur das ist eines der größten Bedrohungsszenarien die wir überhaupt,
Altstadt haben und es ist katastrophal dass nachdem wir jahrelang darüber gesprochen haben
politisch Verantwortlichen Leuten nichts besseres einfällt als einen naheliegend und offenkundig unsinnige
nicht das Problem betreffende Lösung dass da müssen wir was gegen Unternehmen.
Und es wäre schön oder ich begrüße hier dass die dass die Ärztinnen und Ärzte als Interessengruppe sich dieses Themas und ihrer Verantwortung annehmen und ich hoffe dass die A.
Ihrem das was in ihrer Macht steht,
tun um hierfür eine Regulierung zu arbeiten die entsprechende Sicherheiten vorsieht zweitens auch das in ihrer Macht stehende tun,
ihre Patienten und Patienten vor dem vor dem vor der Nutzung von solchen.
Setz setz ins Gesicht schussanlagen wie dieser vivy-app zu zu bewahren.
Ja ist immer ganz interessant mit der verbotspartei CDU die immer so ein bisschen den Trend dazu halt auch hat sowas denn mal auch so
primär glaube ich auch als Einschränkung der wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung zu deuten was die Mutti ja wie sollen denn unsere Unternehmen hier ordentlich auf diesem Markt mithalten wenn wir ihn da so die Daumenschrauben anziehen und jetzt müssen die sich auch noch um so Sachen wie Sicherheit kümmern,
sehen aber einfach nicht das ein Prinzip,
eigentlich die beste Wirtschaftsförderung überhaupt wäre an dieser Stelle mal die Anforderung nach oben zu schrauben ja natürlich ist das dann,
aufwendiger entsprechende Produkte im Markt zu tragen natürlich ist es dann aufwendiger diese durchzuführen und natürlich auch teurer
aber man erreicht damit dann auch ein internationalen Werte Status wo man mithalten kann das wird wenn man dieselbe Logik jetzt auf den Maschinenbau an
sitzen würde dann würde man halt sagen na ja
ist doch egal wenn die Maschinen nicht rund laufen das ist ja billiger herzustellen was werfen wir denn jetzt hier die ganze Zeit den Herstellern Knüppel zwischen die Beine dass man am Ende dadurch dass man das so nie gemacht hat
mit Qualität überzeugt und daneben auch die entsprechende internationale Anerkennung bekommt das müsse dieser Vergleich müsste doch eigentlich jeden sofort gewahr werden.
Genau der müsste jeden sofort gewahr werden was was hören wir ansonsten was hören wir stattdessen in der Öffentlichkeit CDU irgendwas das ist unsicher da muss man halt verbieten das auszunutzen und diese diese brems-und verbotskultur nimmt dann.
Da steigt dann jemand die Christian Lindner FDP natürlich dann drauf und sag digital first Bedenken second was.
Quasi der orthogonal also auf der Ebene der andere komplett dämlichste Vorschlag ist,
beide sind komplett dumm weil sie am eigentlichen an der eigentlichen Herausforderung Vorbeigehen ja und es ist schwierig zu verstehen warum nicht gesagt wird natürlich wollen wir,
von mir aus auch Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen aber wir machen die von vornherein nur.
So wie es sich gehört und wir setzen dafür ganz klare dem dem dem dem Jahr dass wir schreiben,
angemessene Sicherheitskonzepte Verschlüsselungs Konzepte datenschutzkonzepte Daten löschungskonzept für Daten verteilungs Konzepte und so weiter voraus statt jetzt irgendwelche Startups.
Daran zu lassen deren der nachvollziehbar und bekanntes Geschäftsmodell
immer nur darin besteht ein möglichst schnell möglichst viele Kundinnen und Kunden zu binden um möglichst schnell den scheißladen gewinnbringend zu verkaufen
bevor jemand anderes auffällt dass sie die Sandburg auf Sand gebaut war.
Ja und das ist es ist leider leider.
Sehr sehr traurig und man könnte so schöne man könnte so schöne Dinge bauen mit der mit den informations-technologien die wir heute schon haben denn eines darf man nicht vergessen.
Was der Martin auf Zeit sind immer Verstöße gegen,
schon bekannte Regeln der Informationssicherheit und der technischen Umsetzung von Informationssicherheit das sind Fehler,
Verstöße gegen das was schon gesichertes Wissen und best practice der Menschheit ist.
Ja also zum Heulen.
Ja das muss man.
Let's move on das citizen Lab wird bei uns regelmäßig.
Besprochen und zwar handelt es sich dabei um die Forschungsgruppe um Ronald Deibert an der Mank School.
Die an der Universität von Toronto in
Kanada angebunden ist und das citizen Lab ist da eine also eine kleine Forschungsgruppe dessen Lehrstuhl die sich spezifisch mit Angriffen.
Auf Menschenrechtsgruppen auseinandersetzen Menschenrechtler Menschenrechtsgruppen und zwar spezifisch natürlich Chartsoftware Kampagnen die haben.
Im Rahmen ihrer Forschung viele Staatstrojaner Kampagnen entdeckt.
Öffentlich gemacht insbesondere haben Sie diese Pegasus Malware des unter,
nSo Group in verschiedenen Fällen gefunden sie haben Angriffe auf Vertreter von Amnesty International,
öffentlich gemacht sie haben jetzt kürzlich bei dem Mord des.
Journalisten khashoggi den Zusammenhang zur Chartsoftware der NSA Gruppe,
hergestellt und man kann hier wirklich sagen da sind enorm.
Gute Leute tätig die an einer enorm guten Sache arbeiten nämlich der Erforschung und Verhinderung von Einsatz von Schadsoftware gegen.
Zu Verletzung von Menschenrechten und.
Also Journalisten in Mexiko Oppositionelle in Panama khashoggi und so weiter in all diesen Fällen fand man Nebentätigkeit der nSo Group eines der führenden Hersteller für.
Staatstrojaner gegen iOS also zur Infektion von iPhones nicht nur aber auch und.
Die melden die Herz das ist quasi so eine Art gezielte Kampagne gegen Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter der des citizen Lab gab wo,
sie angesprochen wurden sie über linkedin
ob sie denn nicht irgendwie an einem Job interessiert werden ne interessante ist Forschungsteam das war immer so das Jobangebot waren.
Immer den den Fähigkeiten und Interessen der jeweiligen Person sehr.
Sehr gut angepasst und hat sich also der erste Mitarbeiter mit einem Menschen da getroffen der dann irgendwie über Geld reden wollte und dann irgendwann das Gespräch dahin lenkte.
Und die NSA und ob denn die betroffene Person Israel hasse oder und ob sie aus
Antisemitismus immer wieder die nSo Group angreifen würde der der ist dann der Betroffene ist dann halt relativ
mit einem unguten Gefühl nach Hause gegangen hat seine anderen Kolleginnen und Kollegen darüber informiert und als dann der nächste von denen angesprochen wurde sind die etwas besser vorbereitet zu diesem Treffen.
Denn sie haben erst bei der RV Seattle press bescheid gesagt und dann sind sie ja zu dem Treffen gegangen wo dann also beide mit Kamera verkabelt waren also einmal der Ansprechpartner Schienen offenbaren kamera irgendwie im im.
Im Hemd stecken zu haben so ein so ein Detektiv Kuli weiße mit einer kleinen Kamera drin.
Der Typ vom citizen Lab hat halt irgendwie mehrere gopros irgendwo versteckt
beide hatten jemals noch mal jemand anderen dasitzen SV Seattle press am anderen Tisch derjenige der ihn der interviewt hat hatte aber auch offenbar noch irgendwie einen ein Mitwisser am anderen Tisch sitzen.
Und das Gespräch ging dann auch relativ schnell dahin so gibt es Stress bei euch auf der Arbeit weil erzähl mir davon nicht ich liebe sowas ist sowas zu hören dann wollte er mit ihm über den Holocaust sprechen über Antisemitismus
und ob er denn irgendwie die nSo Group hassen würde oder so
und dann kam aber die LP also die Associated Press Journalisten und haben dann gesagt hallo übrigens wir sind von der Association press und ist aufgefallen dass es ihr und,
möchten sich ja was dazu was sagen.
Woraufhin woraufhin der dann irgendwie ich muss ihn überhaupt nichts sagen irgendwie geflüchtet ist dann konnte aber nicht abhauen weil er die Rechnung nicht bezahlt hatte
wenn sich dann irgendwie in einem in einem Hinterzimmer des
des Restaurants versteckt hat und ja also offenbar aufgeflogen ist die lassen sich wieder etwas ihr teepresse noch citizen Lab lassen sich jetzt irgendwelchen Spekulationen hinreißen.
Ob das jetzt irgendwie ne.
Israelische staatlich gelenkte Kampagne oder von der NSA lang IV amateurdetektive waren oder sonstiges klar ist die Gespräche waren relativ eindeutig darauf ausgelegt von ihnen.
Möglichst Kontroverse Aussagen zu provozieren die eben unter Umständen geeignet gewesen wären.
Das citizen Lab irgendwie öffentlich in Misskredit zu bringen denn das citizen Lab hat ein denke ich.
Äußerst guten Ruf in der Öffentlichkeit.
Und den hat es sich natürlich erarbeitet und natürlich wäre es jetzt eine mögliche,
Option diese unabhängigen Forscher anzugreifen wenn man jetzt einen von ihnen in in die Nähe des Antisemitismus bringen.
Könnte nichtsdestotrotz.
Bin ich natürlich froh dass das citizen Lab sich dagegen hier wären konnte und den die Flucht in die Öffentlichkeit.
Ergriffen hat es ist natürlich auch klar wer auf diese in diesem Themenbereich arbeitet der hat.
Mächtige und skrupellose Feinde und insofern kann man das durch alle durchaus als
Auszeichnungen sehen aber das sei natürlich auch allen anderen eine Warnung die sich in ihrer Arbeit.
Mächtige Feinde machen.
Erinnere mich so ein bisschen an 30 C3.
Warda.at Präsentation oder weshalb erinnert sich daran.
Na ja beim 30t 33 Karlsruhe Kirsch Kongress.
Hatte diese wunderschöne Aktion mit den Schauspielern die angeheuert wurden um den um auf Kongress mal
unbescholtene Hacker auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise anzusprechen mit hier wir sind ja ein tolles Unternehmen und können uns nicht mal unterhalten und jetzt mal die Telefonnummer Oma so rauszukriegen wer denn eigentlich
die überhaupt erstmal auf den Leim geht wenn solche Leute anfangen auf der Veranstaltung Akquise zu machen.
Und da wohnt ja dann doch sehr beeindruckende Zahlen veröffentlicht die ich,
wie finde für die Seele an den Kongress recht schmeichelhaft sind also es wurden wir 500 Leute angesprochen von um welchen Damen und so und,
davon haben sich überhaupt nur drei ja zurückgemeldet woraufhin,
da hat mich das jetzt gerade erinnert nass im benachbarten Hotel auch zu seinem Gespräch mit dem Geschäftsführer dem gefakten kam und naja,
zwei von diesen dreien waren halt dann am Abend sich dann tatsächlich überrumpeln lassen und zu einem
zum Unterzeichnen eines n dies bewegen lassen womit dann die ganze Veranstaltung auch schon beendet wurde weil dann wurde Alisa NDR einfach vor ihren Nasen zerrissen und wurden mit einem ordentlichen dududu wieder,
nach Hause geschickt um einfach klar zu machen dass man solchen Angeboten nicht folgen sollte und hätte,
ist ja dann auch mit Kamera gleich aufgelaufen und Mikrofon alvarium Kamera bei Fifa mit Mikrofon bewaffnet und wollte den ganzen Laden hochgehen lassen könntest du kurz noch davon abgehalten werden
kosten rabattsammler zumachen und wurde dann eingeweiht wie du das eigentlich gedacht war.
Also ja das ist schon wichtig dass man da eine gewisse Widerstandsfähigkeit entwickelt und mit jedem sollte klar sein dass nicht unbedingt jede Anfrage die auf einen zukommt,
so gemeint ist wie sie formuliert.
Sehenswert auf jeden Fall das 30 C3 Klausing indem diese Schauspielergruppe das auch noch mal darstellt
und außerdem würde ich bei der Gelegenheit gerne noch so große sich was zu diesem Recruiting Bemühungen auf dem auf den C3 veranstaltung sagen
das sehen wir äußerst ungerne auf unseren Community Events und.
Mir ist irgendwie zu Ohren gekommen dass irgendwelche Unternehmen das auch auf dem 35 C3 versucht haben oder Peng ich davon ob du jetzt gute oder schlechte Absichten hegen in ihren Geschäftsmodellen diese,
Art von Vereinnahmung und wirtschaftliche Ausnutzung unseres Community Events sehen wir,
ganz ganz ganz ungern und ich würde eigentlich jeden Unternehmen sehr davon abraten so etwas in Erwägung zu ziehen das trifft.
Genauso irgendwie die übermäßige Erwähnung des Unternehmens.
Bei Speakern das betrifft solche rekrutierungs Versuche und ich denke wer auch immer so etwas versucht ist tatsächlich mit dem Klammerbeutel gepudert weil auch die Community
da in der Regel nicht besonders verzeihend ist und wir sind sehr stark motiviert das auch so.
Zu so beizubehalten insofern nutzt mal die Zeit zwischen den Jahren für eure Freizeit und lasst mal eure Recruiting Bemühungen,
zu Hause wenn ihr auf unseren Events auf.
Weil das mit dem Staatstrojaner so eine gute Idee ist und weil diese Unternehmen die die betreiben ja so eindeutig vertrauenswürdige Unternehmen sind die,
eigentlich natürlich niemals mit mit denen Autokratien und Diktaturen dieser Welt zusammenarbeiten würden.
Möchte die möchte Europol jetzt auch einen Staatstrojaner haben,
das geht aus einer kleinen anfragen
einer kleinen Anfrage der Linksfraktion insbesondere Andrej hunko hervor der das vom Bundesinnenministerium,
mitgeteilt bekommen hat ja das Europol derzeit nämlich einem marktsichtung für den Ankauf eines Stars Werners durchführt und bis Mitte Februar eine Ausschreibung laufen hat und dann das Projekt anlaufen lassen wird.
Und das BMI schreibt sogar in der Antwort dies kann auch die Frage umfassen ob aus technischen Gründen.
Die Notwendigkeit besteht Schwachstellen sowie Fehler bei Algorithmen und Implementierung bei der Entschlüsselung verschlüsselter Kommunikationsinhalte einzusetzen das ist ja schön.
Übersetzt heißt dieser Satz wir beschäftigen uns auch mit der Frage ob Software gezielt unsicher gelassen wird damit wir sie hacken,
das bedeutet dieser Satz der ist aber natürlich amüsant formuliert dass man sagt aus technischen Gründen die Notwendigkeit besteht was also der der denkt man sehr schnell hier gibt eine technische Notwendigkeit nein es gibt keine technisch notwendig,
es gibt eine
wenn überhaupt politisch motivierte Notwendigkeit dass Schwachstellen auf unseren Geräten geheim geblieben gehalten werden als unser Risiko verbleiben,
und zwar für alle damit ihr einige wenige hätten könnt also wieder und wieder einfach.
Schädliche Bemühungen die hier stattfinden insbesondere wenn es um diese diese Staatstrojaner geht.
Alle Mission mit es gibt eine an einer Hand abzählbar an.
Sah ich mal von Unternehmen die belastbare Produkte in dem Bereich anbieten,
spontan fallen mir ein hacking Team Gamma und nSo ja es gibt noch zwei drei andere die mir jetzt gerade entfallen ZW ich glaube einer von denen ist auch schon wieder platt und alle diese Unternehmen.
Haben Kunden die.
Menschenrechtsverletzungen dokumentiert haben ja das heißt man und das sind deren Kunden diese Unternehmen haben nämlich genau.
Bisher aufgrund der bei uns stattfinden politischen Diskussionen sehr wenige Kunden in lupenrein Demokratien und werden seit Jahren finanziert von eben.
Weniger.
Menschenrechts freundlichen Staatswesen die sowas daneben insbesondere zur Sicherung der politischen Macht einsetzen und offenbar sehr viel weniger für die Ziele der Strafverfolgung die immer,
vorgegaukelt also schlechtes auch.
Auf EU-Ebene was hier droht das nämlich dann die EU-Mittel an diese ethisch äußerst zweifelhaften Unternehmen fließen und damit eine,
Schwächung der Sicherheit unserer Geräte quasi mitfinanziert wird statt dieses Geld zu nehmen dafür zu sorgen dass unsere Geräte besser geschützt,
und dann wundert man sich am Ende wenn wir gesund ist dann auf einmal aus der Cloud weg sind.
So jetzt schauen wir mal in die Schweiz da passiert auch was.
Genau da gibt es eine Volksinitiative für ein Voting Moratorium was ist damit gemeint in der Schweiz gibt es in mehreren Kantonen schon.
So E-Voting Systeme E-Voting heißt du du willst quasi über eine Webseite.
Und das ist natürlich mit allerlei Problemen behaftet,
insbesondere den wird ja nicht kontrolliert ob du wirklich willst oder jemand anders die Sicherheit dieser Systeme die Manipulation San Fähigkeit dieser Systeme
ob tatsächlich am Ende das bei rauskommt was du gewählt hast all das ist hier,
feetje leichtfertig riskiert.
Und dieses Moratorium sagt nun wir möchten bitte das E-Voting.
Verboten wird.
Bis es nachweislich mindestens genauso sicher ist wie das herkömmliche Papierwahl Verfahren.
Und dann kommt die kernform die die die hier die entscheidende ist insbesondere müssen die wesentlichen Schritte der Stimmabgabe.
Von den Stimmberechtigten ohne besondere Sachkenntnis überprüft werden können.
Und Nachzählung müssen Zufall sie zuverlässig möglich sein das mit dem nachvollziehen ist der entscheidende Punkt bei.
Online Wahlsystem.
Und zwar von Laien nachvollziehbar diese Systeme können einfach gesagt.
Geheime Wahl ermöglichen.
Dann ist aber nicht mehr einfach nachvollziehbar und vor allem beweisbar das und wie die Stimmen zustande gekommen sind.
Oder Sie können eine überprüfbare Wahl.
Ergebnisse Silke überprüfbare Wahlergebnisse zur Verfügung stellen dann ist aber die geheim das Geheimnis der Wahl verletzt denn,
der das System muss ja quasi beweisen wie jede einzelne Stimme zustande gekommen ist und wenn es das kann dann kann es auch letztendlich nachvollziehen was jede einzelne Person,
gewählt hat.
Nun gibt es einige universitäre Ansätze die durch mehrfachverschlüsselung und so weiter das Ziel erreichen wollen dass jede Person ihre eigene Stimme überprüfen kann.
Nicht aber die aller anderen einsehen kann und dann wird behauptet dass deshalb das Wahlsystem vollständig überprüfbar wäre und gleichzeitig vollständig geheim was.
Immer noch die Quadratur des Kreises ist denn wenn so etwas behauptet wird diese.
Kann die Allgemeinheit nicht mehr nachvollziehen und wenn wir heute eine Wahl haben mit Papier.
Dann sind einem einem sich mal grob trainiert ein Bonobo diese.
Ist dieses Verfahren einleuchtend ja am Anfang gibt es eine leere Urne dann kommt der Papier rein nachher wird das Papier gezählt
wir können nicht mehr sehen wer wir wissen nicht mehr wer welchen Zettel reingeworfen hat wir wissen aber wer Zettel rein geworfen hat und wir können den kompletten Wahlvorgang,
soll ich mal ob der was weiß ich dritten Schulklasse verstehen.
Und auch seine Manipulationsmöglichkeiten verstehen und seine Kontrollmöglichkeiten vollständig verstehen und das ist die entscheidende Vertrauen stiftende Maßnahme für die Wahl überhaupt.
Und hier wird eben gefordert verbietet E-Voting Systeme für die nächsten 5 Jahre
nach 5 Jahren kann das Verbot aufgehoben werden wenn mindestens genauso sicher und das System nachvollziehbar ist für Laien und das wird im Zweifelsfall da würde ich mich.
Relativ weit aus dem Fenster lehnen geheim und verleihen nachvollziehbar wird es nicht geben.
Von mir aus kommt jetzt irgendjemand mit einer genialen Idee um die Ecke die mich jemand anders in den letzten Jahrzehnten die Menschen sich über E-Voting Gedanken machen hatte aber
ich bin mir relativ sicher dass das unwahrscheinlich ist insofern ist es hier relativ.
Zu unterstützen sie relativ klug und uns zu unterstützen wie dieses Monat Moratorium forget Design einfach nur stand heute,
gibt es nicht für Laien nachvollziehbar und genauso sicher das heißt Nachvollziehbarkeit geheim und so weiter ist nicht
sichergestellt deswegen verbieten wir es bis zum Beweis des Gegenteils und des das heißt hier werden einfach nur über dieses über diese Idee des Moratoriums einfach mal die Anforderungen zementiert die ein System.
Erfüllen müsste.
In der Vermutung dass es kein System gelingen wird und würde es jemanden gelegen dann könnten wir auch drüber diskutieren ich denke nur dass es niemandem gelingen wird und das ist also jetzt eine.
Volksinitiative die entsprechend.
Stimmen braucht in der Schweiz ja ich glaube das war das so etwas wie 100.000 oder so.
Ein Minimum braucht erstmal zugelassen zu werden mal zu.
Ja die brauchen erstmal ich muss gerade schauen.
Also ich glaube das wird jetzt erstmal nur vorgestellt und man kann noch nicht abstimmen.
Wenn ich das richtig im Kontakt bin mit dem.
Chaos Computer Club Schweiz die werden erst in einiger Zeit werden dann irgendwann anfangen zu sammeln.
Und da wird natürlich für.
Geworben werden insbesondere auch von uns also liebe Schweizerinnen und Schweizer haltet die Volksinitiative für ein E-Voting Moratorium auf.
Dem Schirm beteiligt euch daran und leistet diesen wichtigen Schritt zum Schutz der.
Des heiligen Aktes der Demokratie ich denke hier auf ein nicht vertrauenswürdiges.
Oder nicht nachvollziehbare System zu setzen die ist jetzt teilweise in einigen Kantonen schon der Fall ist für Laien nicht nachvollziehbar System das hat.
Unabhängig von der Feder und Manipulation.
Anfälligkeit schon das große Risiko dass jemand die Behauptung einer Manipulation in den Raum stellen kann,
und diese Behauptung nicht mehr von Laien überprüft werden kann ja das heißt wir haben wirkt wir verkomplizieren einfach nur den den Sachverhalt und sehen somit.
Anlass für Misstrauen in das System diese Frage ist schon unabhängig davon.
Dem System tatsächlich zum Misstrauen ist oder nicht aber im Moment haben wir ein Verfahren dem,
wie gesagt ein Drittklässler sein im Zweifelsfall folgen kann und wir wollen das jetzt austauschen durch Verfahren wo irgendwelche IP Experten sagen das hat schon so seine Richtigkeit und,
das ist unsinnig das zu tun wenn wir ein Verfahren haben was einfach und nachvollziehbar.
Fall muss man das ganze ja auch im Zusammenhang sehen mit dem jetzt hier auch schon in dieser Sendung wieder ausführlich diskutierten Rechtspopulismus und der entsprechenden Vorgehensweise
bei so Verschwörungstheorien dass man halt einfach erstmal alles in Frage,
und in dem Moment wo die Dinge einfach unklar erscheinen werde natürlich solche Argumente automatisch dadurch auch unterstützt,
wenn jetzt also irgendeine Volksinitiative wieder mal kommt und so entschieden wird wie es den Rechtspopulisten nicht in den Kram passt,
dann kannst du wahrscheinlich schon die Uhr danach stellen das dann eben irgendwann das kommt mit na ja die mächtigen haben ja dieses Häme manipuliert und deswegen das wäre ja eigentlich alles ganz anders aus,
und dann stehst du da mit leeren Händen weil alles was du sagen kannst ist ja aber hier diese fünf von uns ausgewählten Security Ex,
Ratten sind der Meinung das ist schon alles irgendwie OK so aber ansonsten kann es halt keiner nachvollziehen da stehst,
im Saal und das ist etwas was man insbesondere in der Schweiz ja was er würde ich nun das Land auf diesem Planeten ist was einfach,
dieses Prinzip Wahlen und Volksabstimmungen irgendwie geradezu zu einer Religion nein das.
Dann direkt erstmal Minarettverbot.
Es ist ich korrigiere mich gleich werde ich sprechen nein wo ist einfach eine signifikante kulturelle Bedeutung hat ne das ist das Ganze demokratische Selbstverständnis der Schweiz basiert darauf,
und ist auch dort aber mal in einem Maße noch durchführbar wobei ich sagen würde so für Deutschland funktioniert das schon.
Ja von Großbritannien mal ganz zu schweigen wo wir gesehen haben wo wir dahin gekommen sind wenn du einfach überhaupt nicht die Kultur hast um solche Abstimmung zu machen also Schweizer System wäre ja woanders kaum noch einführbar also muss einfach über so eine lange Zeit,
wachsen sein dementsprechend ist es halt auch wichtig,
dass dieser kulturelle Kids da eben auch frisch bleibt und ich kann das nur unterstreichen was du gesagt hast das war alles richtig.
Der Kern der Kernpunkt ist wirklich mehr es ist vor allem man kann ja diese ganze Debatte machen und nicht lest das ja auch so zwischen ist halt auch ein bisschen raus ne dass man sagt da ja das ist nicht sicher diese Systeme sind nicht sicher.
Vollkommen unwichtig ob die jetzt irgendwie gerade sicher sind oder nicht sondern nur dass man überhaupt nicht beweisen kann ob sie es jetzt gerade waren oder nicht dass es das eigentliche Kernproblem
und ich kann an dieser Stelle und habe das auch schon hier glaube ich jedesmal wenn wir das Thema hatten darauf verwiesen und werde es erst ein weiteres Mal tun,
nehme ich den ca 118
wo ich mich mit Ulrich Wiesner unterhalten habe nachdem in Deutschland das Wahlcomputer Urteil des bundesverfassungsschutzes ergangen ist was im.
Bundesverfassungsgericht tschuldigung nicht der Bundesverfassung.
Katze die ganze Zeit über die falschen Themen,
leider türlich das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts genau in dieser Causa und er
leitet in diesem Gespräch auch noch mal sehr gut hier warum das die richtige Entscheidung war und warum auch nach dieser Entscheidung im Prinzip Wahlcomputer in Deutschland tot sind weil eben einfach
das nicht mehr hergestellt werden kann dieser Anforderung an einen transparenten und nachvollziehbaren Vorgang der ist
einfach mit Elektronik nicht machbar und jeder der das zurzeit noch nicht gemacht hat weil sie einfach mal reinhören.
Dann hat man auch die richtige Argumentation für eine solche Volksinitiative in der Schweiz.
So wir können noch ein paar Daten verknüpfen tippen.
Genau Daten wollen ja auch verknüpft werden das ist ja dieses ursprünglich das eigentliche in innewohnende Konzept von Daten.
Wir wissen dass alle sie hungern geradezu danach dachte sich auch die Polizei konkret
ist in der EU schon seit längerem davon die Rede aus Polizei Kreisen dass man doch den Datenaustausch für Polizei relevante Ermittlungs Daten mal.
Internationalisieren sollte innerhalb der EU spricht es gab schon immer die Forderung einiger EU-Mitgliedsländer dass man auch,
auf die polizeilichen Ermittlungsakten anderer Länder Zugriff erhalten können soll dies.
Befindet sich offiziell immer noch im Prüfungs Zustand also die EU,
dieses Ansinnen aufgenommen und es wird halt geprüft
bisher ist der Status so dass ihm nur ein Austausch über in über rechtskräftige Verurteilungen möglich ist das heißt es ist
derzeit richtig nicht möglich dass du marche Deutschland in Frankreich mal sagt der ok hier Dollar Person wie sieht's denn da aus was habt ihr denn da vorliegen was ermittelt ihr denn da wir würden das ganz gerne auch mal wissen weil wir haben den auch so ein bisschen im.
Das soll sich aber nach dem Wunsch bestimmter Polizei Kaiser halt ändern und die EU ist dem Ansinnen generell.
Aufgeschlossen gegenüber und diskutiert ein
polizeiregister Informationssystem ein europäisches das heißt dann auf englisch ganz geschmeidig European Police records informations-system oder noch kürzer,
kibris.
Weil das eben diskutiert wird hat die EU 2005 also vor 2015 schon eine Machbarkeitsstudie in,
Auftrag gegeben was von belgischen Behörden durchgeführt wurde und dann 2015 vorgelegt wurde
das befindet sich aber offiziell bis heute noch in Auswertung
also die Studie existiert schon seit ein paar Jahren und ist aber offiziell sozusagen noch überhaupt nicht vollständig zur Kenntnis genommen worden allerdings stellt diese Studie ein
grundsätzlichen Polizei fachlichen Bedarf fest sagt also Prinzip na ja das wäre schon ganz geil wenn wir das hätten weil das würde ja so zeigen die Arbeit auch
vereinfachen kann man vielleicht auch nachvollziehen wenn meine gerade Belgien ist natürlich hier in interessanter Fall nicht wahr wir haben diese ganzen
Ermittlung gesehen bei den Terroranschlägen die ist ja in Frankreich zuletzt gab wo daneben die Täter auch in Belgien waren die sind da wird dann eben auch ermittelt
und man fragt sich halt okay alles klar wie kann denn jetzt da eine grenzüberschreitende polizeiliche Koordination
ablaufen und an der Stelle sind natürlich dann den Behörden ebendiese national Grenzen gesetzt.
Hallo Person abhängig davon wie man eben die Auswirkungen davon beurteilt.
Es gibt hier eine Einschränkung ja also zwischen Rheinland-Pfalz und Nordrhein-Westfalen wäre ein solcher Daten austauschen möglich geht aber halt nicht wenn es mir die belgische Grenze.
2018 hat die EU jetzt in Vorbereitung
ein Projekt namens automation of data exchange processes adip gestartet dass es dann so Frank auch schon etwas konkrete technische Vorbereitung man merkt schon also grundsätzlich will man da irgendwie hin nur hat man noch nicht alle Schritte genommen und in diesem Rahmen
hat jetzt auch,
das BKA Software anstatt gebracht um eben diese Vernetzung dezentraler Datenbestände zu testen ja und wenn sich Ihr hier in einem potentiellen Echtbetrieb,
mein
na ja so wie das jetzt hier im Test ist fühlt sich schon fühlt sich mal total real an Wind kommt von vorne,
Regentropfen schlagen ein echt alles total echt bei uns,
wie soll das Ganze überhaupt funktionieren also e-press ist so gedacht dass man hier so eine Treffer kein Treffer mit oder hat mir das so schöne heißt das halt Polizeibehörden
können eine Abfrage vornehmen
bei in einem anderen Land indem sie quasi sagen hier für diese Person hat da da was.
Du musst quasi den Namen sagen oder was auch immer an Metadaten noch zu Identifizierung dieser Person erforderlich ist weil bei Michael Müller wissen wir alle ist das irgendwie bisschen schwierig können mehrere von geben.
Pütt Bürgermeister sein oder nicht auf jeden Fall,
muss dann wenn etwas vorliegt wenn man diese Rückmeldung bekommt immerhin noch mit einer Anfrage begründet werden warum man den das jetzt noch,
haben will das ist sozusagen die Idee was also du bist in der ersten Ausbaustufe noch nicht vorgesehen ist ist ein direkten und unmittelbaren Zugriff auf diese Daten zu gewinnen.
Die Software die das BKA jetzt hier zum Einsatz bringen kommen von Fraunhofer von der Abteilung Focus von Fraunhofer und hört auf den schönen Namen
German University of au pair.
Paul Abkürzung auch mit dieser deutschen deutschen universal Software ist also BKA jetzt gerade,
am Testen echte Test zwischen Staaten handy jetzt hier so nicht stattfinden sollen eigentlich 2018 schon begonnen haben,
Tim so ist bezieht sich unserer Kenntnis im übrigen auch unter Einbeziehung des Europol Informationssystem cis.
Ja also da geht sozusagen auch um die zentrale europäische Polizeibehörde diese Test sollen aber dann mit.
Pseudonymisierten Testdaten arbeiten muss eine ganz schöne Formulierung ist weil das heißt ja dass es sich eigentlich um echte Daten handelt die dann nur,
ein wenig verschleiert werden.
Ja was soll das alles eigentlich also klar man will halt vorallem Reisende Gewalttäter in Griff kriegen.
Da setzte sich die Frage wer hier das erste Opfer sein könnte
mir fallen da halt z.b. die G20 Proteste ein die war ja hier auch vor einiger Zeit ausführlich mal diskutiert haben wie denn das so läuft ja also diese Verfolgung von Menschen die an solchen Demonstrationen teilnehmen
wäre auf jeden Fall hier ein Tage davon kann man glaube ich schwer ausgehen.
Da muss man vielleicht noch kurz ergänzen
es ist ja nicht so dass alle Menschen die zu Protesten auch internationaler Art
anreisen Gewalttäter sind es ist nur so dass die aufgrund der hohen Polizeipräsenz sehr schnell mal in dem Verdacht stehen und dieses diese Klassifikation als.
Gewalttäter politisch oder Gewalttäter Sport passiert eben relativ schnell wenn man im Rahmen solcher Großdemonstrationen,
dann mal von der falschen an der falschen Stelle von der Polizei getestet und überprüft wird ja sie haben ja
das Phänomen muss ja vor dem Hintergrund gesehen werden dass es einige immer noch rechtlich sehr zweifelhaften.
Datenbanken gibt in denen Menschen als bestimmte
Personengruppen als bestimmten Personengruppen zugehörig katalogisiert werden Seil politische
Gewalttäter Gewalttäter Sport und so weiter das sind alles Dateien und Akten
sind Attribute die also Menschen relativ Verdacht und f***
unabhängig mal schnell beigefügt werden wenn sie an an irgendeiner Stelle kontrolliert wurden sei es beim Fussballspiel ne der hatte gab es dann irgendwie Ausschreitung am Fußballspiel war sie dummerweise bei dem dahin Fußballspiel und in der Nähe kommst dann in der Personenkontrolle und dann wird einmal zack bis Sie vorgemerkt und
beim nächsten Mal hast du auf einmal Probleme mit der Anreise und dergleichen Phänomene.
Ja das muss man mal sehen wohin sich das entwickelt wenn man jetzt glaubt es gebe solche Informationsaustausch dann aber entsprechend noch überhaupt nicht auch weit gefehlt denn es gibt ja noch sehr viel mehr schöne Systeme unter anderem das Schengen
Schengener Informationssystem SIS was heute schon sogenannte Ausschreibung zur verdeckten und gezielten Kontrolle
ermöglicht das ist wieder schön formuliert kurzgesagt mit gezielte Kontrolle ist wenn man halt
jemanden in eine Gruppe los schickt und dann wird auch jemand mal komplett auseinander genommen also nicht die Person aber sozusagen die Besitztümer sprichst wird als irgendetwas durchsucht die Person durchsucht Wohnung durchsucht oder eben eine verdeckte Kontrolle die im Wesentlichen nur bedeutet dass Leute beobachtet werden oder immer wenn sie auffällig werden und das polizeibekannt wird dann diese Information der Bewegung
entsprechend weitergereicht werden kann das sind sogar der Artikel 36 fahren und die anderen eben auch europäische Grenzen überschreiten kann
dazu sind dann auch ein paar Statistiken rausgekommen worden die zeigen wie oft denn sowas überhaupt schon.
Einsatz kommt das ist schon relativ erheblich hätte jetzt gerade die absoluten Zahlen nicht im Kopf aber 2018 sind diese Zahlen erheblich gestiegen
das liegt im Wesentlichen an Frankreich also da ist es halt hochgegangen da können wir uns halt auch schon denken woran das gelegen hat die von mir zitierten
Terror Fälle in der letzten Zeit durften erheblich zu beigetragen haben auch wenn es jetzt nicht weiter klassifiziert ist UK ist da auch ganz weit vorne was auch immer die so im primär im Interesse hatten wenn die allerdings für dich im brexit weitermachen fallen sie aus diesem SCR-System sowieso raus das wären sie schon noch
bereuen in Zukunft denke ich mal.
Dann halte ich das Schengener Informationssystem hat also nicht unbedingt mit dem Schengen Abkommen zu tun oder.
Weil Großbritannien ist ja nicht Schengen.
Richtig da hast du recht das ist ein EU Informationssystem.
Ja sie profitieren immer von vielen wo sie nicht will aber dazu beitragen, sehr interessant ne und ich Fall lohnen auszusteigen.
Ja also.
Auch das soll gegebenenfalls künftig noch erweitert werden so dass man eben zusätzlich zu dieser Klassifizierung einer verdeckten Kontrolle
auch noch eben die spezifische Ermittlungs Anfrage bekommen soll so dass dann eben auch dort gezielte Informationen fließen können also nicht nur ein einziges System soll es ist immer mehrere Dinge die hier parallel vorangetrieben werden auf jeden Fall
befindet sich das alles in Vorbereitung bzw kommt noch konkreter im Test zumindest beim BKA.
So und jetzt kann man sich natürlich die Frage stellen wieso soll das denn schlecht sein werden Polizeibehörden,
auch über Ländergrenzen zusammenarbeiten das natürlich nicht schlecht es ist natürlich klar ich meine wir stellen fest dass.
Angreifer im Internet international operieren wir stellen fest dass von mir aus auch der Terrorismus international operiert und ist natürlich klar dass.
Die Polizeien auch über Länder,
Bundes und Bundesländer und Staaten Grenzen hinaus kooperieren sollen,
das Problem ist natürlich immer diese Zusammenfassung von Daten in möglichst einfachen.
Informationssystem und den also die diese vielen Daten an einem Platz mit geringer Kontrolle beim Zugriff da haben wir ja schon,
in Deutschland unsere Probleme mit ein Thema dass wir hier in Logbuch Netzpolitik bisher gar nicht so ausführlich immer behandelt haben sind die Rechtsextremen Polizisten.
Die die polizeilichen Informationssysteme nutzen um Ihre Nazi Kolleginnen und Kollegen zu informieren so z.b. ein aus Südhessen,
Stamm der Polizeibeamter,
der in den Jahren 2015 und 16 Polizeidaten auf Wunsch seiner bekannten Martina H abgerufen und ihr übermittelt hat.
So wäre es Martina H Martina H ist die Anführerin der REM.
Eine also die Arya man kann sich ungefähr vorstellen welche,
welche Aufnahmekriterien diese Gruppe hat und welche politischen Haltung,
ja hat sie und deswegen steht die gute Martina mit ihren mit ihrem magischen Freund Karsten m auch in Halle vor Gericht denn am 1.Mai 2017.
Hat sie zusammen mit haben die beiden zusammen mit offenbar acht anderen Personen mit zwei Autos jagt
auf Gegendemonstranten zu einem Naziaufmarsch gemacht und diese mit Steinen beworfen und irgendwie eine Wandergruppe angegriffen also wir sehen
die Bekloppten Kommissar Autos ob es Islamisten sind oder Aria.
Jetzt gibt es jetzt wird also wegen dieser Angriffe auf Menschen.
Man könnte sagen politisch motivierten Gewalttaten man könnte sagen Terrorismus wird jetzt gehen die gute Martina H und den Karsten m ermittelt oder in die stehen da vor Gericht und die Polizei hatte in.
Zuge dessen der guten Martina auch mal das Handy weggenommen.
Und hat sich ihre Chats angeschaut und auf dem Handy haben diesen Chat mit dem Polizeibeamten Beamten.
Der Polizist ist inzwischen.
Aber auf eigenen Wunsch in Niedersachsen tätig ja der hatte sich also aus Südhessen da verabschiedet es jetzt in Niedersachsen tätig und jetzt geht's ihm hoffentlich.
An den Kragen,
weil das Vertrauen dass wir in unsere Polizeibeamten setzen darf natürlich nicht auf diese Weise missbraucht werden schlimmer tragischer und bedauerlicherweise ist das aber auch kein,
Einzelfall das Polizisten in das politisch rechtsextreme Spektrum abgleiten und dann.
In diesem Rahmen auch ihre Privilegien missbrauchen ja wir haben.
In der niedersächsischen Polizei sogar Reichsbürger ja zwei Fälle.
Wo ist wo in Niedersachsen wo also dienstrechtliche,
Verfahren wegen Verdachts der Zugehörigkeit zu den reichsbürgern geführt werden das auch echt skurril ist ne also glaubt nicht dass die Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
und bist aber bei der Polizei tätig als Beamter im Zweifelsfall noch ne aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht dass es sich alles eine große Phase ist.
Nein nur weil die mir Geld überweisen heißt noch lange nicht dass es dir.
Das Geld ist eh wertlos ich tausch das alles hier gegen gegen Scheine Viking Papiergeld mit Reichsadler oder also,
ganz ganz gefährlich und das darf man eben nicht vergessen das ist.
Wenn wir auf solche Fälle aufmerksam machen dann wird das häufig von Vertretern der Polizei irgendwie als so ein Misstrauensvotum wollte etwas sagen alle Polizisten sind Nazis nein,
aber nicht sagen aber genau damit auch Nazis unter dem Polizisten auffallen müssen eben auch hier
Kontrollmechanismen hin ja vertrauen ist gut Kontrolle ist besser geht auch in diesen Fällen und so einen Kontrollmechanismus kann eben auch eine Einzelfallprüfung sein statt
jeden dahergelaufenen Polizist.
Nach Lust und Laune in diesem System Daten suchen zulassen und seinen Nazi Freundin zu geben die dann.
Menschen in Gefahr bringen.
Ja ich denke dass insbesondere dieser ich möchte noch mal darauf eingehen dass dieser dieses Promi doxing und diese Anti-Antifa Listen und was es sonst noch für Dinger gibt regelmäßig.
Mit schrecklichen,
Beeinträchtigung der Privatsphäre der körperlichen Unversehrtheit der Zielpersonen einhergehen,
und wenn es nun mal dieses Potenzial gibt das Polizisten das ausnutzen dann tun sie es auch wir haben zum Glück genug Polizisten.
Dass wir leider eben auch eine ganze Reihe schwarze Schafe darunter haben und das ist ein Fakt mit dem wir eben umgehen müssen und das ist sicherlich eine.
Ungünstige Idee zu sein lass uns mal die datentöpfe die wir den präsentieren möglichst auch noch international in jede Richtung Ausweis.
Aber das Problem ist halt schon auf nationaler Ebene gelöst werden dafür.
Nationaler Lösung für nationale Probleme das wird den reichsbürgern gefallen.
Na Jana ich meine am Ende muss man auch akzeptieren dass die EU nun mal ein supranationales Konstrukt ist und wer letzten Endes davon grundsätzlich profitieren dass ich die Dinge in zunehmendem Maße auch Europäisierung aber dazu müssen natürlich dann auch erstmal da drunter haben
solide abgesichert sein Gegenbiss.
Genau absolut richtig also natürlich sollen diese Polizeibehörden möglich zusammenarbeiten das gilt auch in Deutschland haben wir ja schon Probleme oder werden ja Probleme beklagt in der Zusammenarbeit der Landespolizeien ja das natürlich soll alle diese
Zusammenarbeit stattfinden,
aber sie soll einer Kontrolle unterliegen und das wird in der Regel durch vernünftige formale Prozesse gemacht und es ist eben schlecht wenn er einfach riesige Datenbanken gebaut werden auf die Jan und man einfach im Rahmen der normalen Arbeit Zugriff hat und die daneben
hier einem derartigen Missbrauch anheimfallen ich denke es völlig in Ordnung zu sagen Mannschaft.
Zeig mal diese Möglichkeit des Datenaustausch ist die muss es ja geben aber eben nicht automatisiert.
Ja da müssen wir die entsprechenden Stellen miteinander kommunizieren gegenseitige Anträge dazu muss es einen papertrail geben und nicht irgendwie Martina H ruf mal bei ihrem Nazi
Polizei Kumpel an und sagt sag mir mal eben wo der oder der wohnt wir sind hier gerade mit dem Auto unterwegs unterwegs und wollen einen überfahren,
ja das geht halt so nicht.
Schauen wir uns doch mal an wie der Trend ist in dieser Hinsicht schlecht genau wir hatten ja schon in den letzten
Monaten auch häufiger darüber berichtet ein Land nach dem anderen fällt in puncto Polizeigesetz
und als nächstes ist Sachsen dran nachdem die Bayern da schon beschlossen haben Nordrhein-Westfalen das ist jetzt schon durch.
Gerade nicht mehr so ganz in der Spur auf jeden Fall auch in Sachsen hat man gedacht auch so neues Polizeigesetz Mama auch mal weil was kann schon schief gehen auch hier ist also ein neues Polizeigesetz,
auf dem Weg was ähnlich wie das eben der Trend in der anderen Ländern gezeigt hat entsprechende rechts und,
Freiheitseinschränkung mitsichbringt insbesondere betrifft das halt immer so diese Bedingungen unter denen Leute überhaupt erstmal in Haft genommen werden kann oder in Gewahrsam nehmen nicht in Haft sein Gewahrsam genommen werden
können wir haben das ja in Bayern schon gesehen dass eben quasi ohne klare Begründung dort Leute im Prinzip tagelang festgehalten werden kann
ohne dass irgendwas konkretes gegen sie vorliegt zwss in irgendeiner Form von der Polizei justiziabel aufgearbeitet worden ist
Sachsen wir das also jetzt auch einführen da gab es jetzt am 26 Januar also am.
Samstag eine Demo war ein paar tausend Leute in Dresden dagegen auf die Straße gegangen sind,
das reicht natürlich alleine nicht aus um hier Schlimmeres zu verhindern sind alle aufgerufen in Sachsen.
Sich bei den Bündnissen anzuschließen da gibt es auch schon ein entsprechend großes
Polizeigesetz stoppen heißt das Bündnis wo sehr viele Gruppen schon dabei sind auch unter einer passenden url Polizeigesetz Strich stoppen.de da kann man sich dann
entsprechend informieren auch informieren kann man sich bei einem
das 35 C3 genau zu diesem Thema mit Constanze Kurz und Marie Bröckling die dort diese ganze Problematik,
zusammengefasst haben und in.
Genau das
also mit mit so vielen Bundesländern die ja jetzt alle diese Novellen anstoßen müssen und bei der Gelegenheit so eigentlich aus Datenschutz Erwägungen da Anpassung vornehmen müssen bei der Gelegenheit einfach noch mal die Schublade aufmachen sagen das hatten wir sonst noch alles für für Ideen
die wahrhaben wollen das findet jetzt in allen Bundesländern mehr oder weniger Stadt und ist natürlich ein bunter.
Strauß der über denen sich erstens schwierig gestaltet einen Überblick zu behalten der andererseits aber vor allem auch jeweils die Initiativen Lokal in den Bundesländern.
Strapaziert und.
Mit einer Aufgabe betraut ja also wir brauchen jetzt gerade in jedem einzelnen Bundesland,
den Protest die Aufarbeitung die Untersuchung und genaue fachge fachspezifische Einschätzung dieser neuen Polizeigesetze 16 an der Zahl das ist nicht mehr von einer
Gruppe zu leisten und entsprechend sehen wir das eben.
Da die sich in jedem Bundesland immer andere Initiativen formieren das ist gut net filtec org Marie hält da den den Überblick und da müssen wir jetzt mal.
In jedem einzelnen Bundesland die einer kritischen Prüfung zu führen schauen wo uns da noch einen ein schwarzes Schaf unter den Paragraphen untergejubelt wird,
und das ist jetzt so die Aufgabe der des vergangenen und den nächsten zwei Jahren Zweifelsfall.
In dem Zusammenhang sei auch noch auf einen neuen Podcast hingewiesen mit dem schönen Namen denk Angebot dass es nämlich der neue Podcast von Katharina nocun also known as
die war ja hier auch schon zu Gast hatten und ja sie hat die erste Folge dieses
Cast hast du dich genau diesen selben Thema gewidmet Polizeigesetze wo sie sehr ausführlich und sehr umfassend durch dieses Thema durch marschiert über einen sehr,
ziemlich lange Marsch weiter als ich dir gerade die sind und das ist Stunde 47 lange also dritte dann noch,
länger und noch detaillierter drüber als wir das beide Logbuch Netzpolitik jemals könnten hat das ganze ab.
Unsere Sendung ist jetzt zweieinhalb Stunden gleich lang.
Ja aber wir reden nicht nur über dieses eine Thema
nee aber es ist wunderbar aufgearbeitet in vielen kleinen Häppchen also fast genau noch mal zusammen die einzelnen Prozesse ist ja aber was eben auch im Einzelnen für Maßnahmen darin enthalten sind
sehr empfehlenswert ich habe die Preview davon schon gehört jetzt ist es dich rausgekommen verlinken wir alles in den Shownotes.
So jetzt aber kommen die letzten beiden mal flotti.
Lotti Karotti Österreicher eine schöne Meldung Smartmeter Verweigerer verlieren ihren Stromanschluss was ist das
eine Kundin im Burgenland will kein Smart Meter haben Smart Meter das sind diese tollen neuen elektronischen Geräte die verschiedene Features mit sich bringen die müssen also nicht nur wie viel Strom verbraucht wurde sollen sie sind
Smart ich hoffe ihr habt die Anführungsstriche gehört warten sie weil sie einerseits einen fernauslesen ermöglichen und damit quasi das
öffnen der Türe nicht unbedingt erforderlich ist weil die Leute nicht selber.
Leute nicht selber gezwungen sind ihre Zähler abzulesen sollen sie übermitteln das daneben automatisch entweder durch so eine funkauslesung von denen aus der Nähe wo quasi jemand mit einem entsprechenden Gerät die Dinger aus ein paar Metern sind 20 m Abstand auslesen kann
wenn nicht sogar dieses Mal mit einer Lage sind selber diese Stromverbrauch regelmäßig auszulesen und
an den strombetreiber Stromnetzbetreiber zu übermitteln.
Jetzt kann ich mal wie du in der letzten Sendung sagen viel zu kompliziert denn Smart Meter kann man einfach sagen dass es AOT am Starkstrom Anschluss.
Goodwill double mit der Erklärung.
Zufrieden ist es gut ich habe es aber deshalb so ausführlich gemacht um zu erklären warum denn diese Kunden das sozusagen nicht wollte,
denn diese Smartmeter liefern halt ByDesign auch alle 15 Minuten also regelmäßig den Ver
und man kann sich schnell ausmalen was das eben für neue überwachungs Potenziale bedeutet wenn man sich am Stromverbrauch auch sehr schön Aktivitäten in der Wohnung nachlesen kann ja auf jeden Fall wollte sie.
Ich haben.
Den Strom zu zu anderen Zeiten günstiger ist doch alles für dich gut dann kannst du nachts die kannst du nachts die Waschmaschine laufen lassen mit dem günstigen Nachtstrom.
Ja das war früher auch schon so dazu braucht man keinen Smartmeter,
ja ich kann ja generell also ist ja nicht so dass es hier keine Argumentation dafür gebe natürlich würde ich als Stromnetzbetreiber
den tatsächlichen Strombedarf einzelner Verbraucher so detailliert wie möglich erfassen können um einfach mal nett besser zu planen weil das ist natürlich das
kein Problem bei so einem Stromnetz jetzt stellt sich die Frage darf dürfen die das
so und in Österreich gibt's eigentlich ein Gesetz Paragraph 83 der Elektrizitätswirtschaft uns
des organisations Gesetzes von 2010 steht eigentlich fest dass Netzbetreiber den Wunsch eines Endverbrauchers kein intelligentes Messgerät zu erhalten
zu berücksichtigen haben was auch immer das wiederum heißen mag und aus diesem Gesetz abgeleitet gibt's seit 2018 eine entsprechende Verordnung in den dieses Widerspruchsrecht zwar grundsätzlich anerkannt wird
aber sich dabei nur auf ihm dieses Feature diese automatischen viertelstündlich
Speicherung Übertragung des Zählerstandes an den Netzbetreiber richtet also das ist dann so ein bisschen das.
Also also du kannst den der Funktion des dismart mit einer bestimmten Funktion widersprechen aber nicht im Smart Meter selber ja und weil das Smart Meter Open Source ist kannst du sicherlich auch überprüft ob sie früh geführt hat.
Genau das ist,
ne na ja auf jeden Fall hat er das jetzt Konsequenzen keine Ahnung wie das ausgeht aber der Stromnetzbetreiber fühlt sich jetzt in Österreich nicht mehr an einen versorgungszug gebunden wenn der nicht auch ein
neuartiges Ablesegerät.
Übersetzer Freilauf andere Phänomen Bereiche ne,
jetzt kann dir der Strom Anbieter sagen wenn du nicht hier so ein so ein Schrott wenn du nicht das Risiko haben willst eines digital Gerätes an deinem Stromanschluss ja welches,
auch wieder mit Unsicherheit und den ganzen Kram er Blackout haben wir alle gelesen das schöne Buch von Marc Elsberg was genau das Phänomen auch die Bedrohung für.
Für die kritische Infrastruktur Stromnetz darstellt durch den Einbau derartiger Smartmeter datenschutzrechtliche Probleme wenn du bei den ganzen Stress nicht mitmachen willst dann brauchst du keinen
dann kriegst du einfach keinen Strom mehr bevor das machen die nicht mit ihren Gesundheits-App,
sie will wie sie wollen ihre Röntgenbilder nicht in der Cloud haben ja dann operieren weil sie eben nicht ganz einfach.
Ca
So Thema Problem Thema gelöst so können sie gucken wo sie bleiben.
Wie Sie wollen keinen EPA Soja increasing kein Perso Sack direkt nach Tür kontrolliert also der phänomenal phänomenal.
Wollen Sie denn 5g haben.
Von 5g Bäume haben das kriegen wir natürlich nicht.
Ne
Es gibt es es stehen jetzt die vier teilnehmenden Unternehmen an der einen 5g Versteigerung fest bzw die vier die sich beworben haben daran teilzunehmen.
Also als einen Antrag auf Teilnahme an der Auktion haben gestellt Deutsche Telekom Vodafone.
Telefonica die also die drei verbliebenen deutschen.
Netzbetreiber die also über ein eigenes Netz verfügen im 2G 3G 4G Bereich und.
1 & 1 eine Marke von United Internet die,
kein eigenes Mobilfunknetz hat sich im Moment als sogenannter MVNO Mobile virtual network operator bei den anderen Kapazitäten Bucht ich glaube bei Telefonica,
und Vodafone kann man sich doch sogar aussuchen ob man D-Netz oder E-Netz haben möchte wenn man sich bei,
1 & 1 1 Mobilfunkvertrag holt die möchten jetzt auch ein eigenes Netz betreiben.
Und jetzt wird die Regulierungsbehörde im Laufe des Februars entscheiden ob diese Unternehmen auch zugelassen werden für die Auktion.
Ist üblicherweise eine Formalie allerdings ist es auch schon mal passiert bei früheren Option dass Bewerber nicht zugelassen wurden also maximal diese vier Bewerber würden dann daran teilnehmen.
Und.
Interessant ist dass alle Teilnehmer eigentlich unzufrieden sind mit den Vergabebedingungen die etablierten Netzbetreiber beschweren sich über die harten Auflagen und.
Haben eine Klage gegen die Vergabebedingungen eingereicht in der sie quasi die die Auflagen dass wir dann auch nicht bauen müssen sind viel zu hoch und,
die Neueinsteiger im United Internet waren eher skeptisch ob die Regeln für die Newcomer überhaupt genug Planungssicherheit bieten ja also.
Bin jetzt in Unternehmen die United Internet kommt und sagt wir wollen hier an diesen.
Milliarden Versteigerungen teilnehmen da muss ja mit dem Zuschlag eben auch eine Planungssicherheit einhergehen.
Also dass sie im Zweifelsfall dieses Geld geliehen bekommen oder die Investition vor ihren InvestorInnen und Investoren rechtfertigen können,
Probleme die wir nicht hätten wenn wir sowas als Infrastruktur.
Des Landes oder des Bundes bauen betreiben und dann den Anbietern gegen einen entsprechenden Obolus zur Verfügung stellen.
Aber jetzt gibt's also erstmal dieses.
Diese vier Bewerber Unternehmen und wir werden.
Wie sich das entwickelt inzwischen nach Peter Altmaier ist nun auch unser Bundespräsident.
Unter die Mobilfunk runtergegangen und Steinmeier sagte wenn ich im Grenzgebiet zu Frankreich Tschechien oder Polen unterwegs bin dann habe ich oft kein deutsches Handynetz geschweige denn überhaupt mobiles
Internet zum Glück war das ausländische Netz so stark dass ich darüber telefonieren konnte,
sagt also Steinmeier ja ich bin froh dass die Jungs echt mal bisschen übers.
Von mir aus auch mit ihren mit ihren Diesel Treckern lass dir ruhig mal die.
Die die die Landluft schnuppern.
Dann hilft das nämlich danach Scheiße riecht in unserem Mobilfunknetzen und vielleicht wäre schön wenn sich daran etwas ändern würde wir haben ja in der Folge mit Thomas Rudolph schon ausführlich darüber gesprochen das sit,
nicht unbedingt danach aussieht dass wir dieses Problem in näherer Zeit loswerden.
Aber haben wir wenigstens auch weiterhin Themen für das obwohl.
Glaubst du für Frank-Walter wird jetzt auch LMP weil wir so wie der jetzt seine Texte formuliert hat Machtgefüge der schreibt ihr einfach ab.
Stimmt er letztes Jahr erstmal aber er ist leider das Problem mit soll ich mal um Fakten Würdigung bemühter Berichterstattung ist eben.
Dass sie die Leute immer erst dann würdigen wenn sie nicht mehr im Fakten schaffen Business sind ne.
Lass das ist das Problem.
Frank Walter hat ja lange Zeit auch selber Fakten geschafft.
Jetzt wurde nach oben weg befördert und muss sie nur noch kommentieren da geht natürlich eine entsprechende Freiheit mit einher.
Damit wären wir jetzt am Ende der der Themensammlung zu beginnen vor der Sendung nicht gesagt hin wenn wir uns kurz fassen schaffen wir diesmal auch ein paar mehr Themen in der gleichen Zeit das Projekt ist denke ich als gescheitert.
Zu beurteilen.
Ich guck mal kurz wer am meisten geredet hat das Zimmer.
Ich habe ja auch am meisten zu sagen.
Dann mal los schnell Abspann.
Ja ein Dank an Armin und Wolfgang ist hier noch herzlich mitgeteilt.
Okay und ich bedanke mich bei dem einen Spender der nicht nur jetzt angefangen hat für Logbuch Netzpolitik
monatlich einen Betrag zu überweisen sondern auch gleich dankenswerterweise auch noch für die letzten 5 Jahre diesen Betrag mit überwiesen hat als beitragsnachzahlung.
Das wollte ich jetzt erstelle mal würdigend erwähnen.
Das ist sehr gut weil so entgeht man dann eben auch die Strafzahlungen der letzt der Logbuch Netzpolitik einzugszentrale.
Die kommen die kommen unangekündigt zu Hause vorbei und prüfen ob ihr ein neuartiges Empfangsgerät habt ja und entsprechend wird dann ein geringer Beitrag erhoben.
Zieh dir bitte an uns zahlt.
Genau euer Einhorn Status wird sozusagen erhoben.
Die Logbuch Netzpolitik Einhorn einzugszentrale sehr sehr vielen Dank für jegliche Unterstützung die unserem Projekt hier zukommt.
Wir bleiben dabei darum möglichst selten zu werden und uns den Inhalten zu widmen.
Du zahlst also das war es bis bald Leute.